this is jaco podcast number 270 with
echo charles
and me jocko willink good evening echo
good evening
i'd made a mistake that was going to
cost me my life
i turned to the man beside me he was a
yemeni
we called him h and he was the only
passenger in the beat up local car i was
driving
the air around us was was stiff with
heat and tension the vehicle almost
rocking as the press of humanity outside
began to shove towards me
pointing i kept my eyes down not out of
fear
but so that they didn't get a good look
at them through the dirty glass
i knew exactly what had happened how
they'd spotted me
i was dressed head to toe as a local
from flip-flops to a turban
i had a dyed beard and my skin
colored but what i hadn't added to my
disguise
was my brown contact lenses and now my
bright blue eyes were drawing the locals
in to point and stare i knew it was only
a matter of minutes before
the neighborhood bad guys started
slipping out of their hiding places
and tonight i could look forward to an
orange jumpsuit
the last thing the world would see of me
was the image of a former special forces
soldier about to meet his end
courtesy of an enemy unfamiliar with the
geneva
convention
bollocks i wanted to talk to h i wanted
to
the local man's opinion but if the
people outside saw my lips moving in a
funny way
then we were truly [ __ ] and so instead
i raised an eyebrow and hoped that
people would just think i was commenting
on the traffic that had packed us into
this bustling marketplace
h gave a shrug in reply as if to say
what can you do what could i do
get my head chopped off or go out
fighting those seemed to be the choices
i knew which one i'd choose if it came
down to it but i couldn't help but hear
the voice in the back of my head
the voice that had told me always you'll
never last
two minutes in the army well
if this was the end i'd show them how
wrong they were
i've been showing them for years
this wasn't my first covert mission as a
civilian
i'd cut my teeth as a special forces
soldier and
as such i'd had my medal tested again
and again i tried to remember that as
yet another local pointed at me
and began waving towards my door i
pretended to be busy looking ahead at
traffic and checked the mirror behind me
no sign of our second car i wanted to
rub my eyes
despite the danger i was knackered maybe
that's why i had made the mistake
maybe that was why i had to get on my
radio
hidden away out of sight from the
yemenis who continued to walk by
peering in and pointing at me i kept my
message short trying to move my lips as
little as possible
i've been compromised
my mate sam came on the net from the
second vehicle
he was out of sight but i was sure that
he couldn't be more than 100 meters away
are you compromised over
he asked i confirmed that i was
are you happy with the immediate action
drill over
i knew that drill off by heart the first
part would involve me
pulling a snub-nosed machine gun from
beneath my seat and emptying a full
magazine into the windscreen
this would send a very loud signal that
it was a good idea for people to get
away from me
it would buy me seconds to grab my
wrapped up assault rifle
wedge between the seat and the door and
exit the vehicle
then me and my flip-flops would be
racing for the nearest safe house
sam came back on the net
your call out
my call when it comes down to it the
biggest moments in your life
always are
i thought about letting out a deep
breath but looking
ice cool in front of h was important to
me
fear is contagious and so i put mine on
a shelf until i got clear of the
situation
instead i imagined everything that was
about to happen in this [ __ ] storm
bloody hell i almost laughed to myself
all this
over a pair of contact lenses
i looked at h gave him the slightest of
nods he was probably sending up a prayer
at that point
maybe more than one my own thoughts went
to my wife
and children if someone wanted to stop
me seeing them again
then i promised it would be a fight like
no other
and then with the thought of my family
pumping like fire through my veins
i reached below my seat and took hold of
my weapon
and that is the opening
of a book the book is called relentless
and is written by someone named
dean stott who is a british soldier
who served as an engineer in the
commandos and eventually went on to the
british special forces selection and
became one of the
first army soldiers to opt into joining
the
special boat service counterpart to the
british sas
[Music]
and that is just the beginning of this
story
and luckily for us dean is here himself
to help talk us through
his experiences in the military and
beyond dean thanks for coming thanks for
coming aboard no pleasure having me
it's been a long time that we have been
getting requests to have a brit
on here so you're the you're the first
well we had we had one photographer
who had been to iraq but i think you're
our first british
military person and there's been a lot
of requests oh brilliant
great so glad glad to have you here man
no pressure
yeah the whole the whole nation is
riding on on your shoulders
so um
the that's the beginning of this book
and the beginning of the book
starts off it's sort of the middle of
your
your operational career when you talk
about the military operations and then
civilian operations
but i guess we should start at the
beginning i always like to start at the
beginning of you know
where you came from and and how you
ended up in this particular situation
in life and um yeah let's get to it
yeah so i was um i was born into
military family my father
he was in the royal engineers and um so
very much immersed
in that in that environment and i grew
up in a town called aldershot which was
the home of the british army so
it's just airborne heavy you had two
parallel you had free paradise i'd never
even heard of the royal marines or the
special boat services
i mean it was just sas and airborne um
my father and my mother they ended up
splitting up when i was quite a young
age um
by the age of eight my mother um left my
father and took me and my sisters to
manchester up north
and we ended up in a homeless home in
moss side and moss side back in the 80s
was the roughest estate in the whole of
the uk
now now when brits say a state yeah
when you see when americans say a state
they're thinking of like a country
estate with big houses
when brits say a state you're talking
about the ghetto yes it is a ghetto yeah
and it's it's a government housing right
is that what isn't a government housing
estate that's where the word estate
comes from yeah they call them council
estates
and yeah obviously to get your your name
on on the housing
market you have to then go into a
homeless home so that's what we did we
ended up in a homeless shelter
in moscow and you know i was the only
white me and my sisters the only
caucasians in in the area so we were
attracting attention
from an early start the you know this
soon ended up with me learning how to
fight with my fist quite early you know
protecting my sisters in in the school
playground actually i ended up having to
leave that school because there's too
many fighting and we moved to another
another place within manchester my
mother we then
got housed in my father however used to
travel up
and pick us up every other weekend it's
about 240 mile drive one way
and take us back down me and my father
were very close my sister was very close
to my mother and three years later my
father got custody
you know of me and my sisters um wow
that's that is that heart i mean america
it's pretty hard for uh
especially a military dude to get
custody
yeah over the mom yeah no there was i
think obviously
you know he he put his career on pause
he got promoted to regimental sound
major and was posted to germany and he
said no i want to stay in uk
i want to look after my kids and so he
put his whole career online
and i think the judge at the time um
didn't want the siblings
splitting up you know he didn't want
like two sisters being in manchester and
the sun down south so
the judge said no the children made the
decision
and being the eldest at the age about
ten and a half i had to make that
quite hard decision and said no i want
to live live with my father and he he
got custody and i and
you know even to the day i remember the
day that my mum dropped us off and the
reaction she saw when my father took us
away you know that sticks with you
something
something like that but for me we moved
back down to older shots
and you know i'm very close to my father
i never actually wanted to pursue a
career in the military myself i
always wanted to be a fireman um but we
we grew up around there but my dad is
he was a scotsman he was old school
sergeant major he was old school
uh through and through and i remember
finishing like junior school and we went
on to
what you call high school secondary
school and so this is what age
what age is this well i would have been
about 13 at this age
so at 13 you're you've been living with
your dad for a few years now
and you're seeing the military but
you're still not quite
you're not quite um like enthralled by
it
yeah yeah no as i say when i was
immersed that our school playground
uh was where the red devils used to take
off which is the um
the british parachute and free fall
teams every day you'd see the parachutes
the guys would be walking around in
their
their uniforms in their maroon berets
and it was just it was almost like
the the norm living in older shots so um
but my father was now going to
transition out the military my father
his career wasn't
very um he was more sports it was what
we would call a track suit soldier
he was very good at a sport and and
soccer was his so he was the army
manager coach
and player so i very rarely saw my
father in green kit you know it was more
track suits trainers and
on the football pitch so i didn't really
know much about the military and
and the layout of the military and um
was it was he going on deployments
uh he he went on deployments to like
norman island
um but that was but when he then got
custody of the kids
you know that obviously stopped him
going on on any deployments and this was
a period of time actually
you know the last conflict was 1982
which was was the falcon so
there was a dry period up until now we
had the gulf war in 91
um but that was still to come actually i
was two years two years later so
other than northern ireland there wasn't
really any sort of overseas deployment
so it didn't
didn't really affect him going away um
but he was
now coming to the end of his career and
transitioning to sivi street
so growing up in older shot in these
military schools
um he then decided to put me in
secondary school in
a local town it's called north camp um
but being old school
my my father dressed me up day one in a
blazer
carrying like a a briefcase a leather
briefcase you know it wasn't even real
leather that's what i was more
upset about um but my hair was
was a crew cut you know rather than
going downtown and paying for a normal
haircut my father would take me to camp
and just put me in straight at the front
of the queue with all the recruits
and that's legit yeah so i really stood
out when i turned up at school day one i
i stood out
wait so is this school what kind of is
this school like a pr
what we call in america a private school
where you have to pay to go to or what
was different
no it was a public school but it wasn't
in a military town it was next to the
military town so
the children that went there their
parents weren't from the military
because it was so close to aldershot
there was a lot of rivalry between and
so the haircut
just just i just stood out and um yeah
unfortunately a week later i got
suspended from that school for fighting
like were you just an angry youth or
what
no i just think i'll just put in some
really awkward positions
and that that being one but i always
remember my father i know you guys do
brazilian jiu jitsu you know
my father again always taught me to
fight with my fists and as soon as the
guy
we call that scottish jiu jitsu
but as soon as the opponent's down
that's it you you know you stop
you've got the bear of them and um
there's no like follow-up like there
isn't
nowadays so i i was so nervous when i
got home
and i sort of left the left the letter
on the table and quickly
ran upstairs to the toilet my father
could you know
screams out my name and um i come down
and his
his one question was did you did you hit
him when he was down i said no he said
that's fine
and then i had to i then explained to
him i said look
you dressed me in this this and he he
just thought he was doing
good by me when in fact he was bringing
too far too much attention
um we then left actually not long a few
months after that and moved out into the
country
um totally away from any sort of
military town and and that was almost
the start for me that was the start of a
new life you know i'd left that military
background
behind me um so how old are you now i'm
probably about 14 now
right on and and then you get to where
where where did you move to when
you got this new start so it moved to uh
into surrey so it's just south of london
but it's more very very green um the
country
the country exactly and now did you uh
how was that was that like uh you said
it was a new start
because you were able to fit in a little
bit better your dad didn't shave your
head to send you to school
yeah exactly there was no military
barbers but it was also that no one
could judge you
you sort of left your your past behind
you you know manchester
fighting and um you know it's almost
like
this is the baseline you start from now
so um
and again it was actually nice to um
socialize with kids
whose parents weren't in is learning
stuff that was out that military
lifestyle you know all my friends back
in older shot their dads are all
airborne because my dad wasn't they
called him a hat
you know i mean it was just like he
didn't have any of that i didn't have to
prove anything to them or feel like
you know you know because your father's
career you're you're part of that and
that's what older shot was like it was
like what ranks your father
is he para is he not and it's like oh
god i had a friend who was uh
who is australian sas and
he was saying you know him and his wife
we were talking and he was like
they're they have an expression it was
like oh their wife wears the rank
of the family so it's like oh you know
he's lieutenant colonel who
are you it sounds like but i can't
imagine little kids
telling me my dad's not airborne oh yeah
that's
great why they call him a hat uh it's
just saying that the parachute regiment
call him hat i don't know
we say helly airborne troop but it's
it's not they just call them a hat
because they they don't have
the maroon berry and then you know some
of the army commandos
also take on that terminology and call
them call them hats or screamers
we in the army the american army they
call someone that's not airborne
a leg and it's said with such disdain
i remember when i went to airborne
schools i committed you nasty
leg and then in the
the in the navy the the
aviation guys people that are in
helicopters or jets or whatever planes
they wear brown shoes it's part of their
uniforms so they call
in a derogatory way they call anybody
that's not a brown shoe
which no one's used that term but they
call everyone else a black shoe
and so then in the teams we take that
one step further and like the
derogatory who's that guy some shoe came
over and told us if
we couldn't wear that whatever so that's
uh it's funny how you get these little
little little words that stick but hat
yeah hat is the parachute regiment and
then the marines obviously from the army
it's pongo
little kids telling you your dad's a hat
yeah
yeah and again no wonder you had to
fight on a regular basis yeah
if it was airborne i'd probably been all
right
and then so so so you end up in in
surrey yeah you're in the country
do you feel like your life's taken a
better direction so your dad was a good
great athlete apparently
did you inherit that athleticism and
love for
the game i did yeah i think that's where
you know i'm very competitive
i like to compete and i i think that's
you know from my father you know even
on christmas day with the board game it
got that competitive
um you you had to win you know and um
you know so i did inherit that that from
him
um sport wise i and i i followed in his
footsteps you know played
uh played football as well i wasn't
great at sport but i just
tried everything you know i was very
fortunate at school i ended up getting
sports personality at the award it
sounds amazing
yeah but i wasn't the best at football i
wasn't the best at rugby you know
i just helped out you know if they said
right we need someone on the basketball
team well
i don't really know basketball but i
would step in so
so i saw ins had that from my father but
um
and i think that's what helped later on
in the military career
you know i always found myself competing
with others or having to prove
prove a point or be an ambassador well
that's two different things actually
prove a point or be an ambassador yeah i
don't know how that's that's like
that's two different things right if i'm
trying to prove a point that's one thing
if i'm trying to be
it's like one's gonna come at you the
ambassador is gonna be cool so you found
that nice
like middle ground between those two
things yeah well i found myself that you
know when you're in the army and you
you are working alongside marines you're
an ambassador for your cat badge
if that makes sense you know what i mean
and then when you go to the sbs from the
army
you're an ambassador for the for the
british army when you're on jocko's
podcast and you're the first british guy
you're an ambassador
so i was proving a point to myself into
them but
almost representing your unit or your
cat batch
so you talked about you wanted to be a
fireman and in the book you
in the book you
it sounds like at some point you realize
there's a lot of applicants to be a
fireman
and like thousands of applicants to be a
fireman it's sort of like in america we
get a similar thing here but yeah
you realized it's probably not going to
happen yeah well
back to the schooling my father again
being old school he wouldn't let me go
out and play unless i did my homework so
he would check
everything so in school-wise i did quite
well i didn't look
beyond school i didn't look at college i
thought i was just going to join the
fire every day
and you had to be 18 anyway so i was
still underage
and and at the time there was a big
recession and it was 2 000 applicants
for one job i i went to college
um but every summer holidays as a young
kid my father
would take me and my sisters down to the
southwest of england to
to cornwall and we would go surfing so
i've been surfing since you know a young
boy
so during college we had a two-week
summer holiday so me
my mates are out right let's go down to
nuki none of them surfed but they just
wanted to try and find gills so wait you
know we all went down to nuki
um for two weeks um i was in the water
all day and they're just
just sat on the beach doing their thing
and um
i met a norwegian guy called yarn and
um you know we just got chatting and he
was a silver surface waiter
uh at the local hotel so fistral beach
is actually on the the surf tour
at the pro surf tour official beach
hotel is on on the peninsula
and he said well i'm getting 30 pounds a
day i i serve breakfast
i get free breakfast i serve i surf all
day and then in the evening i serve the
evening meal and you know i get a free
meal i get 30 pound in my pocket is only
10 pound for the hostel
i thought brilliant you know being an
entrepreneur i thought i'll have a piece
of that
so two weeks later my father came to
pick us up
and this is now where you're talking 94
long before
any mobile phones and things like that
and i wasn't in the car park with my
friends
and my dad said where's dean and they
said oh he's staying
so so your friends met your dad
yeah my dad dropped us off and he came
back to pick us up two weeks later but i
wasn't there yeah so
again i just didn't want to confront my
dad and i didn't want to go back to
college so i just didn't want to get
into an argument
so when you got done with what we call
high school how old are you
so we're about 16. okay so then your
college starts after that and this is
taking place during this two-week break
you go down there you're surfing yeah
you're
living the dream and you see this
norwegian cat that's got it all figured
out
and you figured you're in yeah that's it
that's my life full planned out loud the
road map
um my father then came back six months
later
you know looking for me uh and he found
me working in a local surf shop
and he's you know right you know you've
messed up your education that's it your
life is over you know
giving it all all these all these little
one-liners so for me to really just
silence it
i just said well i'll join the army and
you normally
expect some you know warm comforting
words from your father but i've sort of
met with a response
you'd last two minutes um probably
wasn't the response i wanted but i
thought
okay no there's no point in getting into
an argument and the best thing to do is
try and
prove him wrong but i was about five
foot seven
and 65 kilos so i could probably see
where he was coming from
at the time but he drove me back down to
surrey and then
the following monday you know we went i
went into the careers office
did your dad go with you no he didn't
but his office was only 400 meters from
there so i i walked in
and it was in older shot obviously para
heavy airborne
and i came out and i went to my dad's
office said i'm joining the parachute
regiment
he says you're bloody not and march me
straight back in
um i didn't obviously he was royal
engineers i didn't
know much about the royal engines i
didn't know that you actually can do pee
company and be an airborne engineer or
do the all-arms commander course and be
a commando engineer all i'd known was
him playing football so when he actually
explained a bit more to me i thought
okay that's a good idea
and he wanted you to go engineer so
you'd have some kind of a civilian
skill set whether it was building or
pouring concrete or whatever
skill you're gonna get yeah he was
thinking obviously short term i'll
probably do minimum three years you know
be a bricklayer a plumber so but also
within the military there was a trades
and b trades your b trades in the
engineers were your artisan trades which
is like carpenter
plumber you know everything else and
then your a trades was like
you're electricians and uh plant
operators so the big jcbs and diggers
so my dad said what about a plant fair
um so i was out gardener i didn't know
what he was on about he said no
he then explained but again before that
once
once he'd marched me back in the office
a week later i had to go in and do this
touchscreen test
and basically i passed it they said you
can choose any trade you want
obviously back in 94 i was thinking more
with my my penis
and i was thinking bomb disposal that
sounds sexy
i said let's go bomb disposal so i went
to my dad's office i said i'm going bomb
disposal he said you're not
and he just marched me straight back in
and then he said right why don't you be
a plant fair
and again you know he was he was sort of
carving my path or put me in the right
direction
you know if i stepped off and that's it
so then so
then you're enlisted and how long was
the
was the weight between when you enlisted
and when you actually shipped off to
basic training
it wasn't long at all about two two to
three months um i went to a place called
purbrite you you have like a
um it's almost like an acquaint you know
three days there
you do all your fitness tests and then
you speak to other recruits you know
get their perception on on basic
training so i was actually i think my
dad pulled a few
few strains because i seem to get get
quite quick
to start point than others and then i
in the book you say you basically say
that basic training is what basic
training is what
is there anything that shocked you about
it did you feel like you were pretty
ready for it um again
my my father you know he started
steering things i i had to turn up
uh it's a place called bassembourne and
all i'd known about bassembourne is
where they filmed full metal jacket and
memphis belt and that's the only
research i'd done on it on this place
um but you had to be there um
from zero 800 in the morning to 1700 at
night you had to parade
on on the sunday actually between those
times my father had me dropped off
at 007.55 with my hair already cut
and my bag already packed because he
knew it was all about first impressions
you know if you start coming in you know
just over five or about half four
you know i mean the the the instructors
were already march or cards
but i i had arrived at five to eight and
i i stood there from eight o'clock till
five o'clock in the
in the in the evening so you know in
reflection going back i know why
why he did it at the time it was raining
i didn't appreciate it
but you know it's a culture shock uh
training everything you're you're sort
of used to having your
your home comforts is taken away from
you guys who did have hair
soon lost their hair and we all look the
same um but it's good
you know it still instills that
discipline from from the off
how long is british army boot camp
so it depends what what cat badge so for
the royal engineers we do
um 10 weeks basic training and literally
that just
is as what it says it's basic training
we then have phase 2
combat engineer training which is about
14 weeks and then you go on if you then
want to go do the commando course
the commando course is 10 weeks as well
so if you start putting them all
together it can be quite long if you
join
the royal marines that's nine months
from from start
to finish um so yeah it all depends
on what cat badge you're going to but
originally basic training is about 10
weeks
and then you got picked up to become
when did you get picked up to become a
physical training instructor
yeah so it seems like they had a lot of
faith in you out of the gate or was that
your dad working behind the scenes
no well what it was when i when i
finished uh my phase two training
um i i got my post in order and i
remember ringing my
my my dad and my stepmom uh penny and
i said yeah i've got posted to 2 8 and
then she starts crying
on the phone and my dad's that picks up
the phone he said what have you said to
penny i said i've been posted to 2-8
and i can hear him in the background he
said 2-8 not q8
like that but what it was because my
father was the army
manager two-way engineer regiments were
in germany were the army champions
football champions in germany so it was
like you're thought son
so you're coming out to germany so
i i got posted to hamel at the age of
18.
um which at the time was good you know
it was the deutsche mark before the euro
it was like must cost about seven
dollars for a crate of becks at 24. you
know
you know i was seeing germany which
which is now
collapsed now everyone's back in uk but
as soon as i arrived my side major knew
that they call us kiss ballers the
footballers
you're a kiss baller he goes i'm not
going to see you because literally it
was almost semi-professional you didn't
work
you trained every morning between 8 and
12 on the astro turf
and you had a bit uh a big match every
wednesday afternoon and then we used to
all play
play semi-pro uh for local teams
so he knew that he was never gonna have
me as a soldier
so he said well i need to fill a slot a
billet in the gym
so you're going on your pti course and
that's how i managed to get it fast
tracked
so so quickly and then what that course
consists of
so i flew back to hold a shot and it was
right next to one of my old schools
and and it's basically you they get in a
position that you can you can teach
physical training so when you go back to
units there's different types of
training you can do you can do gym
uh pt you can do green pt um the hardest
thing is gymnastics you actually have to
do gymnastics and it's like
you know it's like a flying track suit
just throw a t-shirt in the air probably
look more elegant than me
um but it's just so you're in a position
when you go back to the unit
you can run pt sessions and then you end
up from there
you get done with that and then you now
is when you check into 59 commando
yeah there's a little period before
between that
so when i was in the gym i was like i
could see
i could see me almost mirroring my
father's career and i was like
i don't want to be a track suit soldier
you know i want something different
so you saw the possibility of mirroring
your father's career
and something about it you didn't really
you wanted to be you wanted to you
wanted to get after it
in a different way yeah that's it yeah i
wanted to do do something different
and so i actually filled out the
application form for nine squadron
and five nine um but actually on
reflection so nine squadron is the
airborne engineers
which is back in older shot where i grew
up and five nine commando
is down in north devon and it's you know
surf heaven down there
you know i've got saunton beach croyd
beach um so for me
we are in san diego and he's from hawaii
so maybe it's not quite surf heaven
probably yeah it's england we'll give it
to you for
but for me i you know you join the
military because you want to you want to
see the world you want to
experience new things i didn't want to
go back to older shots so five night
commander
was well suited for me so i applied for
five nine commando and you have to go do
a four-week beat up with the unit before
you can go on the all-arms commando
course
so you go to the unit first and they
kind of do an assessment
that's it yeah and then and then from
there you go to
that's sort of like ranger school in
america you can go to ranger battalion
and you haven't been to ranger school
yet
and then you go to ranger school that's
it yeah it's like that
but back in germany during this process
when the paperwork was in
um one of the one of the squadrons had
just returned from northern ireland
and they had like a welcome back party
in the camp camp bar
there's a course called um assault
engineers where infantry can come do
engineering courses
and there was an infantry unit called
the fusiliers who were on camp doing
that but they'd
they're troublemakers basically they
were banned from downtown because
they're always causing trouble so they
were on camp
this evening that they had the big uh
the family get together they were in the
bar as well
and me and my friend could see they're
being quite rude to some of the
we call them pad's wives you know the
lad's wives you know
so me my friend you know decided to open
up on a couple of them so we ended up
you know putting down three guys my my
my sergeant major came in is that right
you boys go to bed you know it's brushed
under the carpet
i was then rudely awoken by a military
policeman two hours later said
you're under arrest and um
so before i went over to five nine
commando i there was possibility
that i could be getting caught
marshalled for this fight
so i went over anyway i did the first
week of the beat up
and then the course staff started pulls
me and he said you you've got to fly to
germany they're doing an id parade
i was like okay so id parade is some
kind of investigation
investigation with the police yeah they
want to line you up with other
other other guys and are you are you
like totally distraught at this point
um i'm not totally distraught you do
worry about your career how this can can
affect your
your career so i i flew over and
me at the time i still hadn't grown into
my ears so i just stood out like
you know a sore thumb and and they all
knew me as the pti
so straight away they just beelined yeah
that's the guy
my friend who did it with me however his
his brother was in the squadron as well
so he never got picked out
so i was like okay great um so i flew
back to
finish the beat up you know they said
yeah you're fit enough you're ready
so when on and did the did the commander
course and
um when we finished the command of
course ten weeks later we go back to
five nine commando
and the oc is like that he said right
guys you guys are going across the water
and the squadron were in northern
ireland so i thought perfect we're off
to northern ireland he said not you stop
he said you're going across the other
water you're going back to germany
he said we need to get this get this
cleared so i went back to germany
and um basically they said look you can
go court martial and it probably would
get thrown out but that's gonna
be another 12 months to 18 months you
know i've just passed the command of
course i wanted to go
be with the commandos so i just pleaded
guilty
um i got charged and so i spent 56 days
in the military correction training
center which is colchester prison known
as the glass house
and but the the commanding officer
actually because everyone knew
it was me and the other guy you know
they and they knew these guys were
troublemakers
they're like yeah you just unfortunately
got caught out so the commanding officer
was an airborne guy
airborne engineers this is the
commanding officer at colchester no no
this is
this is the gym yeah no this is in
germany okay you know so i have to leave
that unit first
and so the rsm matches me and the rsm
was one of
a football player with me and uh and
he's like outright
you know sapper stott um i was going to
give you 60 days
but because you've done the all-arms
commander course i've taken four days
off
any questions i said yes if i'd gone
airborne would i got more days off
and he sort of giggled and he said like
you know it's time for you to go so
so yeah i spent 56 days in her majesty's
corrective training center yeah i was
looking i didn't know what colchester
was but it's basically
it's the same term echo charles when you
hear somebody say leavenworth what do
you think of
prison yeah military prison that's kind
of the way culture is i think it's the
last
military prison really in england
there's so there's
not it's everybody knows it the glass
house it's the glass it's the equivalent
of leavenworth yeah and
and everyone has you know you hear
horror stories coming out of the glass
house
and what and what it actually is is
because when
you you have an escort that drops you
off and the instructors are there to
meet you and it's like it is like a
scenario full metal jacket they are
screaming and shouting at you but as
soon as they've gone
they just treat you like adults you know
i mean it's um they take away all those
sort of
those creature comforts you know you
don't you're not allowed to phone anyone
it's um two pt sessions a day
it's room inspections all the time i
actually really enjoyed colchester
um i said if i got paid full
full wages i would i would have really
enjoyed it and it got to a stage
actually where guys were going into
colchester
and coming out better soldiers a lot
better soldiers and they were actually
getting promoted when they got back to
their units and they had to stop that
they said no it's
you know you're there for the wrong you
know for bad bad reasons you can't be
seen to be
be promoted so i did i did my time there
and um went back to five nine
right rewind a little bit to the
commando course yes how was that
yeah so i remember my father dropping me
off
at driving me to north devon to do the
beat up and then you know i
obviously hadn't told him about the
incident in germany at this point and he
said you know these guys will
you know these guys will will make you a
man you know what i mean so you're
obviously
really nervous about things like that
but um but it is that the beat up's
great you know
the five nine beat up they actually is
harder than the all-arms command of
course
so if you can reach their levels and
their expectations
then as long as you stay away from
injury when you go on the all-arms
command of course
you should be fine so the all-arms
command of course is for
any cat badges so engineers artillery
anyone who's going to be serving
alongside
free commander brigade with the royal
marines or any naval
um you know doctors dentists as well so
you've got a mixture on on that course
and you've got guys who are
young privates all the way through to
quite senior officers who may have just
been
attached to the brigade and we also have
foreign
um foreign militaries there i remember
we had a seal
no a marine on our course as well us
marine on our course we had some guys
from lebanon we had some guys from
russia you know he had all sorts on
there
and basically they get you to a standard
so you're understanding
the royal marines sort of ttps their
sops so when you go to unit you
understand how they operate as well you
know
you do amphibious warfare as well i mean
you also do
their commando tests so they're commando
tests you know the 30 miler which
is the last one to get you your green
beret and all the
all the other tests that build up to it
and it's 10 weeks long
and i could be a doctor that's going to
get attached to i could be a
39 year old doctor that's going to be
attached to commando and i got to go
through that and get a 30 pound
rock on i think for them they they have
they
they volunteer for it you know they can
still serve with the brigade but it's
almost like
you know i mean you they see that you've
made the effort and you've got to covet
a green beret
um you know probably they get less
pressure if they've done the course
but actually saying that the navy guys
were really good because
a few years later which would touch and
i ended up being an instructor on the
on this command of course the navy guys
because they have no military background
before this
they've not picked up any bad habits so
what the instructors were telling them
they were picking up straight away
whereas you may have a a sergeant or a
staff sergeant
who's you know been in 14 years and he's
already picked up
his little bad habits it's have happened
to you know realigning or reset
that whole whole uh [ __ ] um but for us
our course i i didn't learn anything if
i'm on i learned nothing on our course
um
every one of our instructors got sacked
at the end of the course our course was
very
officer heavy and it was like
we weren't allowed to wear gore-tex if
it rained we didn't learn anything
so who could survive in the cold and and
who was the fierce
actually learning anything soldier-wise
i picked up when i got to the unit
but that backfired on the instructors
because at the end of the course they do
like course critiques you know how was
your course
and could it was so officer heavy that
they went to town on them oh
they went yeah yeah they went to town
because enlisted guys get handed a
critique and they're like
good good good good i'm going to get a
beer
officer's like well let me state my
opinion on this matter
oh yeah they backfired it every every uh
instructor got sacked apart from the two
army guys the engineer
and the artillery officer but for me i'm
still i'm only 18.
i'm you know you're still developing as
a young man you know i wasn't
i wasn't fully grown i remember the load
carries being you know really difficult
you're carrying some
excess weight there um and it's very
different from like pea company the
parrots
that's all more that they're leaner and
then they go faster with
with less weight with the commandos they
sort of tend to be bigger guys
uh carrying more weight but a slower
speed so you know i
i do think that's probably one of the
hardest courses still to date but that's
because i hadn't developed
yet fully now i got to pull this one
section out of the book because i
thought it was worth reading this is
when you're in colchester
and you have this conversation you say
drink was a big problem in the forces at
the time
i'd be surprised if it isn't still and
so when i was interviewed by the officer
of the prison
i was grilled about my alcohol
consumption
you were drunk when you hit the other
soldiers correct yes sir
so do you have a drinking problem no sir
i'd have hit them anyways
hmm what happened to your wrist and this
is another thing you explain i fell out
of a window sir
trying to urinate sir were you drunk
well yes sir hmm so you don't have a
drinking problem
i didn't really know how to reply to
that one as far as i saw it
it was just part of army life part of
being a squatty
if i had a drinking problem maybe the
whole army did personally i felt like it
was just being one of the boys the
officer dismissed me
and then you go on to the fact that you
enjoyed being at colchester
which is which is cool you had a good
time
but that's uh that's one of those things
as i was reading it i've
i had quite a few conversations with
young
seals you know hey so
you've gotten another fight at a bar
right that's why you're in here talking
to me
yeah were you drinking yeah and you also
were here three months ago
and you were also in another fight in a
bar and you were drinking
you see any common things here no
any commonalities between these
incidents no i don't know
mm-hmm i like to fight i guess
[Music]
i gotta watch out for that one
you get to um you get to to
fif do you call it five nine or fifty
nine five nine yeah you get to five nine
and uh i thought this was cool couldn't
have asked for a better beginning to my
time at five nine the admin officer took
one look at my report from colchester
seemed happy with what
he saw and ripped it up fresh start but
it was a lonely start the rest of the
squadron was in northern ireland
finishing the tour i'd missed out on
doing to my due to my time in
kali i was gutted not to be a part of
that but it ended up working my favor
we're sending you on a diving aptitude
course
usually guys have to wait years to get
on this so consider yourself lucky
so because the other guys were deployed
in northern ireland you got an
opportunity to go to this dive course
yeah that's it so in the royal engineers
we we have divers
so everything um you can do on the
surface be it
um broco cut in um
welding carpentry scaffolding everything
we we can do subsurface do you guys call
that hard hat diving
um the osds which is the open supply
dive assist and the kirby morgan helmets
that that's part of it so scuba is part
of it
and and and so and so is that but we
group everything
if you're not doing combat swimmer
operations like if you're just if you're
doing any kind of work we just call it
hard hat diving
it's a hard hat diver it's like good
it's good for you yeah but like
yeah that's the way we classify anything
that's not dragger
combat swimmer ship attack you know it's
like hard hat diving
hey before before you dive into that so
this this
going to colchester that's is that on
your record or when that guy shredded it
was it gone
i think it stays on my record i think he
was just trying to prove a point is you
know withdrawals
fresh start but actually a lot of a lot
of guys do well in the military a lot of
these rsms you look back especially the
guards they've been to colchester
it was almost you touched on it then and
that you'd brief up a guy for drink and
then three months later you come in and
you tell him this again well obviously
he's he's making a mistake
i learned from my mistake and i learned
at an early stage thankfully it didn't
happen later on in my career
um and then obviously i have bigger
consequences because i still didn't have
rank at that point
yeah you know yeah no it's i so in the
in the navy
you have service stripes on your uniform
and if you've never been in trouble
those service stripes are
gold so in your dress uniform when you
see a navy guy a navy
master chief or a senior chief and
they're in their uniform
they'll have service stripes so it's
like one stripe for every four years
so you can have a lot of stripes after
28 years yeah and if you've never been
in trouble
they're gold but if you've been in
trouble if you have like a captain's
mask or something like that
they're red and it was it was always
interesting to see that there would be
guys that would be master chiefs and
they'd have
they'd have red stripes i mean they got
in trouble at some point in their career
and the reason i asked that is because
you know it's a
as more and more focus
sort of more and more attention to the
seal teams
you know it was like a lot less of a
there's there was more of a
zero defect mentality right and if you
got in trouble one time it was going to
stay with you and it's going to be a
problem so those gold
versus red stripes was it kind of like
it's kind of cool to have the red one or
is it kind of cool to have the gold like
what is it
it depends on your assessment of the
situation that's what i mean like what
was the common
like the culture like if you seen a guy
and one guy had a gold one guys not a
huge deal not a huge deal but like btf
tony yeah yeah
red all day he's one of my buddies and
he's like you know just a
break glass in case of war type of dude
and yeah he had bread so it kind of
depends on the person's like personality
like it's a case by case yes and this is
this is
you know back in the day when guy yeah
you know when guys were getting in
trouble more because
there's also less going on and really a
lot of it boils down to leadership too
you know if you're if your
leadership isn't giving you stuff to do
and pointing you in the right direction
where do you end up if you're 18 years
old if you're 21 years old
if you're 19 years old and you don't
you're not giving good direction where
do you end up as a as a
young male where do you end up echo
charles
jail well possibly but definitely in a
pub definitely
you know being aggressive definitely
doing that's what you're going to do
and so if you haven't gotten some good
guidance then it's going to be
problematic
and you know we're getting better at it
but it definitely is
it's good to hear that you could you
could have a
a mistake like that and look you could
how many times did you not get caught
right
of course yeah plenty of times this time
you got caught
it's good that you could get caught
learn a lesson and move on it's also
very interesting that
people would come out of that highly
disciplined environment highly
disciplined environment in colchester
and do better as humans
yeah do better as soldiers that's
freaking
legit that's proof proof of what
proof that discipline equals freedom
well that that's kind of a good deal
where like yeah you can go to
prison essentially and get what i mean
would you call it rehabilitated like if
you're improved
absolutely out of it i mean isn't
shouldn't that sort of be the goal
i think so yeah i think so you know like
i said it's
you know we we have something similar we
don't have the the bands on our
arms but if you have 15 years of of of
good discipline you get the long service
good conduct medal
yeah you have things you know to aspire
to but
you know i think everyone will get in
trouble as as long as you learn from it
it's character building as well you know
thankfully for me
it was at an early age my good friend
now he's he's the rsm in the ses he was
in colchester prison with me as well
so but that's what it started to be
almost like oh
uh people are getting promoted and
that's the wrong reasons for be going
there
um but as you if you come out a
different man different soldier but like
i said the instructions in there were
amazing and that's probably
you know that was reflective on the guys
when they came out well it's interesting
that you actually call them
instructors and not guards right when
you go into the
navy brig if you're in the marine corps
in the navy you get in trouble you go
into the brig
and those are guards they're not
instructors so it's kind of cool that
they were actually trying to well do you
think that they were trying to teach you
they were trying to
move you forward yeah well you have
military lessons it is just being
on camp but you're just locked up at
night that's the only difference
um you know you are going to uh you're
doing drill you know the guards
like today we're going to take off on
the runway and then just be marching as
fast as you can i mean you have
the gym instructors and then you do
aircraft recognition you'd be you'd be
on the ranges you'd go for runs pt you'd
run out
at the camp gates and i remember running
like that thinking
but i knew that if someone wanted to
take a bolt for it and you stopped them
it reduced your sentence i was i was
keeping an eye out you know for any sort
of yeah
oh really sharp move you tackled
somebody yeah yeah yeah
but i think you you have an interview
when you go in and they
they sort of say you know you've got all
sorts in there you've got guys who
who don't want to be in the military you
know you've got awhile you've got guys
with drugs you've got you know
you know there's all things and and when
i you know you just honestly
look i got into a fight and a lot you
just got caught that's it at the end of
the day
they understood they've probably been in
the position you've been in before but
just didn't get caught
so so it's like more i mean it's like a
different approach essentially
then like you know like when you think
of prison outside of the military you're
like no that's your punishment
straight up like you you're it's
essentially like the the difference
between a beating
and a counseling kind of thing so like
you know what you're talking about it's
kind of a counseling like hey you did
this
let's let's let's kind of reap benefits
from this whole situation
improve you well they have programs like
this now that i think about it they have
programs like this
in america i don't know if they have an
england but they take kids that are on
the wrong track and they put them into
like a highly disciplined military
militaristic environment and it
definitely can straighten them out
i sponsored a kid going through one of
those things and went up there and saw
what they were doing and it's like
a lot of those kids really turn around
and start doing well yeah
so yeah and then but then if you just
get the beating it's like you just
it's yeah it's just a different approach
right it is more effective
i think for the military you know if you
come out a different person you know if
you come out and then you reoffend then
obviously there's a problem
um but i think it's almost like yes it's
one strike yeah
because you you can go in and you have
28 days in under and 28 days and older
there's like two different wings and you
sort of look down
you look down at the 28 days you said
that in the book you're like i'm
competitive about it you guys are over
here for 28 days i'm big time
i mean you got the ones actually were
going to get discharged from the
military as well
but rather than just throwing them out
the gates they would go do
plumbing courses cut up into courses so
there was stuff there there to help them
here
man that squared away okay so i cut you
off when you were starting to talk about
dive school
i'm sorry but yeah no it's yeah so um
but for
so the royal engineers have divers i
think we have about 450
um divers at the moment and and
basically
what um when i was in germany there was
always things on orders
asking for guys who want to go on a dive
course because everyone's heard of p
company the para course in the all arms
command of course but the dive course
i think is probably one of the most
arduous and underrated and underrated
courses
but it's also an additional quote so you
get you get more money back
back in the day when i do it was only
two pounds 65 about five dollars a day
uh but now you're talking you know 20
pounds so 35
40 so there used to always be
anyone want to go on a course right
exactly yeah exactly
but there was they'd struggle to get
volunteers from
other units because of the guys from the
airborne engineers and
commando engineers because that's
already physically robust that
there's a waiting list you know you are
at the back of that list um
but because they're all in germany so
all in northern ireland
still out well you're going on the app
shoot so i literally must have just
fast tracked two or three years to get
on the on this course
so i went and did my my aptitude and now
i've seen diving change
over the years this was back in 90 in
97.
um and it was it was called a deska
diving set self-contained compressed air
it's like scuba
but it was no comms we don't have any
comms it was nil visibility
uh the only way we communicate we had a
lifeline uh
that rope around our chest with a bow
line and they just do pools and bells
so it's an alien as you know underwater
it's an alien environment and so a lot
of guys don't like it but for me
i've been surfing and i i love the water
it was almost like for me i'm more
comfortable underwater
than i am on land so so i did that
course
came back and the squadron had just
returned from northern ireland so here's
me now in this new unit
just stolen everyone's dive course which
everyone's on the waiting list for
uh and they've obviously heard i've just
come out of colchester prison so there's
a couple
there was a couple of names within the
unit like you know
squadron bullies and they're like oh
wait till such and such
uh sees you and i thought here we go we
had a christmas party and
uh one of the lads just comes over he
said oh you think your hand in just
just full-on straight in the face god
so i you know i just i just right hooked
him back and you know
he stepped back and said that's all i
needed to know and uh
i think that's sort of you know getting
my foot in the door
within the unit but what five nine
commando
used to be the army minor unit boxing
champions
and each year they were because they won
the final they'd automatically
go to the final the next year and each
year our opponents were the airborne
engineers
so this was coming up in january three
months training i didn't have a choice
to like well
you've been a corchester prison you're
on the boxing team not really
so um so we went i just spent three
months did you ever box before
i did in in guildford where near surrey
uh one of my friends from school we went
to a place called bell fields
so i did a bit of boxing then again my
father didn't want me boxing
and i sort of had an agreement and said
well look i'll box until i get beat
and then you know then i'll stop so
thankfully i never i never got beat i
only had two about three fights i think
when i was when i was there
but in the military in five nine
commando it's it's just pure fitness
there's no boxing skill uh at all and we
would have three or four pt sessions
um a day and rather than like lose the
weight
over a period of time they lose the
weight in a short period and you've got
to maintain it
but um three months later we had the
army mine units finals
and there's other guys from the squadron
based at other training units and
there's you could see him reading the
book like
who's this start who's this new lad and
we thought we were going to walk away
with it and at the interval it was too
all there's seven fights of the night
it's too all at the interval
and remember the sergeant major coming
in and he's just like in my chair she
said you need to do you know
poking me right in the middle of chest
and i was like oh my god and um
i came out and i had tears in my eyes
the adrenaline
was pumping i went out and i knocked the
guy down uh
three times in a minute and 20 seconds
and and that literally you know
i'd made my mark within five nine
commando and i settled in quite well
that's awesome good story um
you go you go here in the book you say
it wasn't it wasn't long into my time at
five nine that i was selected for recce
troop
a kind of elite within the squadron it
was a huge privilege as recce was known
as being a great stepping stone towards
the special forces an idea that i'd
begun
to toy with thinking about my future in
the army
so you end up in recce troupe that's it
yeah so
in free commander brigade you have five
nine commando
engineers that support the brigade you
have two nine commando the artillery
and within free commander brigade they
have their own
sort of um reconnaissance troop called
um
brigade recce force or brigade brigade
patrol troop
from the marines which consists of
snipers and mountain leaders
but also part of that group is naval
gunfire
from the artillery and also five nine
record troops
so we're almost like eyes on the ground
advanced sides on the ground you know
giving
input on potential combat engineering
tasks so
you have to be selected from record
troop within five nine commando and they
they did that in norway so each year we
used to go to norway for three months
and the whole of the brigade and we do
arctic warfare training it was all
due to the cold war if the russians were
starting to head west across norway that
we'd be able to you know
to stop them so you know and norway's
an equalizer and that separates the boys
from the men so i'd got
my name have been picked up to go
wrecking troop and um
so yeah so very fortunate to get
selected again
at a young age to go recce troop and
within five nine commando it's actually
classed as a posting
so my time had started again as i
entered in into record
as you touched on there a record troop
had a 100
pass rate for uk special forces
selection so guys
i would see guys leaving and and never
come back um
so for me it was when i then started my
head started turning towards
the opportunity of special forces you
know my dad told me i had last two
minutes i managed to
get through basic training i've done a
pizza i managed to get through
colchester i managed to get through the
command of course i'm now
just about to get my my para wings and
you're also then amongst
like-minded individuals those who want
to go or aspire to be special forces so
um
so yeah that was wreckage route for me
did you did you go through any
official training for recki trip do you
have to go to a school or is it just
from the unit itself you get trained up
they they had their own selection
process with it within the unit and then
you used to have to go do p
company which is the the airborne
engineers uh course but when i
when i got there our troop staff
sergeant you know said there's no need
to do p
company you know we would run our own
selection process which
disgruntled some of the older boys they
felt no you have to do p company um
but there's a big difference as well now
in the guys that were going wrecking
troop compared to the guys of old
guys of old were like you jocker they
were just huge you know
they were just massive guys it was all
about fitness whereas
now you know the world was sort of
evolving
the balkans had kicked off and so five
nine commando went to
um bosnia and wreckage we went to to
kosovo with brigade recoforce well this
was the first
operational tour for record troops since
the falklands war
um so the guys in between that period
hadn't seen any action
and then we then uh when i went over to
kosovo which was great for us
yeah you say here uh one day i called
home to the uk with news from my dad
he'd probably forgotten long ago about
our two minutes conversation in the car
i hadn't i had a big smile on my face as
i gave him the news i'm going to kosovo
i told the old soldier
i'm going on tour and this is in this is
in 2000 so if you were going to do
something real
going into going into the going to
kosovo was
as good as it was going to get at that
time at that time yeah
then um what what types of missions were
you doing there
so brigade wrecking four so we were we
were doing as a you know forward
observation
um for example one the first i mean it's
in the book actually the first stop we
went on
it was like right we're going on the
ground we're on ops uh
and so basically there was a 5k buffer
zone between serbia and kosovo
and they didn't want any sort of any
serbians in there any cosmons in there
because that you know that's where it
was all kicking off
so a lot of our work was on the border
but there was also
those that committed horrific crimes
crimes of war as well so we were also
identifying these hvts getting imagery
from them and then obviously getting
guys to come in and pick them up so we
were having a grab
no camera kit straight off civilian
shelves walking in with a great big lens
and things like that
and uh i remember the first job we went
on and
we inserted we had our intelligence
brief we inserted
and as we were patrolling you know to
the frv
i was a real man and i kept hearing
something
sort of that stop the team
get down on one knee you know all round
defense i'm all looking through our size
you know
there's nothing there but you can hear
almost like the creeping in the leaves
you know someone's sneaking up on us
anyway
this carried on all the way through we
got to the position
even when we're in the op position we
could hear it um we've got the imagery
we needed and about you know two weeks
later
we extract it through the field for two
weeks in the field the whole time you're
hearing this noise at night you hear
these
probable enemy approaching your position
yeah ready for the fight the whole time
you're thinking of the worst you know
you shouldn't be there and things like
that and uh
so when we extracted um we went back to
camp and we
we have the a debrief and like you know
any point something like yeah
you know i don't know whether we were
compromised it felt like i will
compromise but there was a lot of
movement
you know especially at night and then
some some
you know corbin call them green slime
the intelligence core
this guy that i i did forget to mention
it's breeding season for the tour toys
so actually what we were hearing was the
tortoises
coming out to mate but it kept the whole
patrol on stand two for two weeks
uh so you guys are doing recon patrols
how big of teams are you guys rolling
out with so we're in six-man teams
yeah 690. and and you're staying for up
to two weeks out there
yeah we we did four weeks once um yeah
we we got to
um basically we got an int report in
that there was a
a training camp in the 5k buffers and
the serbians basically said
you deal with them or we'll deal with
them and so we inserted remember
you know snow on the ground as well and
because we were arctic trained we were
the best guys
for the job so we inserted did our tents
and we're in
observation ops for for four weeks
and um just feeding back all the
intelligence and they were it was a
military training school they were doing
heavy weapons training small arms
training it was quite well disciplined
and we were actually then relieved by
the americans americans you know
came in and took over from us four weeks
later
and i think subsequently from that sf
did go in
and actually take down take down the uh
the training camp
but um for me yeah four weeks in in the
snow
um you know separates the boys from the
men
what's the op tempo like when you'd get
back how how often would how much down
time would you get and then you'd roll
back out
uh we'd be rolling you know we'd
obviously de-service and resurface it
was
everything from urban to rural you know
we were doing stuff as well
in in in vehicles we had snipers in in
the tall buildings in the middle of
pristina um so the jobs would
range from that to you know we did get
into about one
one of the local government guys is
gonna be an assassination attempt on him
so we're obviously having to keep an eye
on him all the time as well and i
remember actually
seeing two guys and we got out we were
in civilian attire
and we walked up to walking up towards
him because we see you could see the
guys that we knew were going to take him
down and they caught our eye and they
caught theirs and they just went the
other way and actually it was a dry
rehearsal
we just compromised dry rehearsal they
weren't doing it then
which obviously kept him alive probably
for another month i think he did get
assassinate after we left so you had to
be
how old are you right at this point yeah
nine nights i'm 22. yeah so you're just
all kinds of fired up for this is living
the dream oh yeah there's everything
everything
you dream about and read about yeah
doing it for real
you you go through this uh this here in
the book as you close out this chapter
we were just about to head home from
kosovo when we were fastballed onto a
task
going to apprehend a bomb maker we were
told and the adrenaline began to buzz in
my veins
sitting through the intel brief we
learned that someone had been cooking up
bombs that were being used to take out
politicians the bomb maker wasn't
the one using them he was more like a
chef for hire
understandably nato were keen to get him
off the streets
i wasn't the one to grab him but a
couple of the other guys
bundled him into the back of our
vehicles of our vehicle
his hands were tied behind his back and
despite our orders to keep his eyes on
the floor he kept looking up and around
him
i put a hand on the back of his head to
help his concentration
that's bang out of order the man shouted
in a sharp
manchunian accent as i've ever heard so
it's a manchester accident
my jaw dropped and i looked around at
the other guys in the team
not for one moment had we suspected that
the bomb maker could be a fellow
countryman
when we dropped him off for questioning
i bet he wished he'd stayed at home
there was a solitary chair in the center
of a courtyard
with two bright spotlights shining onto
it very james bond
we left the bomb maker to answer for his
crimes it was time for us to go home
so you guys were running those those are
great ops you know yeah great ops
getting bad guys
um who'd you turn them over to who's
gonna interrogate him
um it was our intelligence services yeah
relatively gentle then
uh so then this is the point where you
get uh the offer to or the
selected once again to go be an
instructor yeah that's it yeah
linstone am i saying it right listen
yeah limpstone so
you go to limston to to be an instructor
of that commando course
which you which you had gone through and
the one that you said everyone got fired
yeah yeah that's it yes
and so how was that yeah great it's
great privilege to go back
so so what we used to do uh with five
nine wrecking troop we
each each troop within five nine had to
have a guy who did guard duties
and things like that so we were exempt
from guard duties and from that we would
send an instructor
on the commander course for a year so
you're actually again it was classed as
a post in outer unit but
you're still attached so again when i
talk about
being an ambassador you're an ambassador
now for the cat badge and this is only
about four years after
me doing my own course so i always
remember my course thinking well you
know when we were on our course we had
to
build build up the uh the instructors
tents you know we were doing a lot for
them when i got there it was night and
day you know we
did our own tents um but instruction had
changed completely
they we were doing everything that the
students were doing we were wearing the
same equipment we didn't have any
you know gucci kit as well we were
wearing exactly what they
they had and because you were you were
as an ambassador you obviously had to be
seen to be doing what what they were
doing which i thought was a great way of
teaching don't ask for them if you can't
do it yourself
and and so yeah it was night night and
day
the we had a couple of instructors on
the course and you know i soon learned
how you can get the most out of of your
students i know when i was on my course
you know i didn't learn anything and i
always remember that i thought well i
don't want this
to happen to these young boys you know i
want them to be in a good position when
they go
to their unit because you're going to go
back to five nine and you're gonna be
serving along
alongside these guys as well but we had
a couple instructors and they would just
come out every morning just scream and
shout
you know i mean i think the the marine
instructors they felt they
they had a bad bad deal going on the
all-arms command of course
um but in fact actually they enjoyed it
they really opened their eyes to how
good these guys were at soldiering
you know the marines because it's nine
months long they're so
proud of their tradition and they see
these you know
army guys coming in and doing ten weeks
but they don't realize what they've done
before that before they've got it but
these guys would come out and scream and
shout and then and you can see this
student's eyes it's almost like
straight in the press-up position and
you know they've got nothing back
um whereas for me it was all about the
banter it's about a humor you need to
have a sense of humor and be
approachable so if i
had to tell them to do press-ups i would
do the press-ups with them
i remember also there was a law that we
could only do 30 press-ups
really a law yeah within limstone yeah
they started introducing the maximum you
can do with 30 press steps but there's
ways you can get around that you know
because
you can do a press up you can do a half
press up you can hold it for a few
seconds
and then fully down you know so we we
did that i mean there's way ways around
it
but for them as as students you know
i was seeing a better product at the end
than probably what they did of me
uh four years before so i did like i did
like that change
do you feel like you were able like i
was very lucky because i was
gotten new instructor roles and was able
to teach i
taught everything it was awesome i felt
like i learned a lot while i was
teaching because now you're observing i
mean from a leadership perspective you
know i was
when i was at e5 so i was like a young
junior guy i was
teaching the young officers that were
going through our basic it was called
seal tactical training at the time
so i'm out there telling them how to run
immediate action drills and telling them
like hey no one's listening to you you
need to step back you need to take a
look around
i learned so much from doing that did
you feel like you in this instructor
mode
got to learn yeah i got to learn learn a
lot myself yeah and
and like i said we call it the sugar
pedestal we used to have to always do
the demonstrations before the students
so it's like
do not mess this up so our drills had to
be had to be slick and
and quick but on my first course we had
the first
female candidate to do the all-arms
commander course
yeah she's in the book you call her what
lieutenant why lieutenant
yeah yeah we had to protect her name for
legal reasons but um
she'd done two she had two previous
attempts
and this was her third attempt and so
the instructors
who took her on her initial two uh
courses
were dismissed from the training team
and we had another training team sort of
come in so you can already see it's
going to be it's getting steered that
way
so basically um what it was is
they wanted a female to pass the
commander course and people don't
realize this actually
basically if a female hadn't passed the
command of course
they were going to lower the standards
until a female pass but that would be
standard throughout
male and female so the fact that she
went on and passed
we didn't lower the standard so people
don't see see the bigger
the bigger picture behind the scenes
so so when you talk about her in the
book she didn't pass
it's not that she didn't pass there was
two ladies on the course there's
lieutenant y and i'll say lieutenant x
uh lieutenant x was a a doctor who's
actually from five nine and
she did everything that was asked of her
you know she she struggled
and things like that whereas lieutenant
y was almost playing the system
she knew that if she could go to the
doctor she would get two days
light duties but the way the timings of
that used to always before
the commando test so she dressed up for
a couple of days for the commando test
and it was that it wasn't the fact she
didn't it was the fact that she played
the system well
um lieutenant x you know she i remember
one of the guys
uh daz who went on to be chief
instructor to the sniper school we were
doing some
close quarter cqb and
he you know you'd follow the student
through and then at the end
you'd give him a debrief and he's like
he comes through with a student who said
that guy was brilliant and and then me
and him started chatting and as we
looked over it was like a scene from a
shampoo advert she took her helmet off
and just brushed her hair down
and with the both our jaws hit the floor
and there's that
i said well if she was good you tell her
you know you tell her that she was good
and he did yeah you're excellent but
unfortunately week five you do your
your bottom field test which is like a
an assault course and you have to climb
a 30-foot rope
and she was about a foot and a half just
below that rope so she didn't
progress on that course but i do think
you know if she had
none it instructed without any qualms so
was that lieutenant x or lieutenant wife
left
left in an x okay yeah and but you're
saying eventually
she did make it through lieutenant uh no
lieutenant why she
she made it through on that course she
made it through on that on that course
and
it was almost to just dampen the white
noise you know
whitehall we need a female to pass we
need a female to pass um but you can
imagine
what the airborne lads were like you
know i mean it was like oh my god you
know you used to get phone calls my
wife's on paternity leave for 10 weeks
can we
come down and do your course
it was a good banner and you also talked
about a
guy that was what 50 something years old
yeah just a beast
yeah so you know even when you know
lieutenant y passed i was getting blueis
from the lads there in afghanistan yeah
well done you know i mean it was like
you know lads some
special forces don't even bother coming
on selection it's like a big thing a
female passing but to be honest you know
she deserved to pass and i generally
believe that if you deserve to pass
you know you've earned the right and so
yeah the next course this gentleman
turns up captain fox
and he's basically going to be the
family officer 2-9 commando
this guy's 55 years old and he did pee
company four years before i was born the
airborne you know i mean
so uh we're there we were there on
parade and the first thing we do is we
do a um
i think we're doing a six mile boot in
march and it was spring
and we came back and it like you just
thrown two buckets of water over this
guy
and i was like i said are you all right
you know captain photos it goes oh yeah
i had pneumonia you know 15 years ago so
i can't control my
my my sweats i was like oh my god this
guy's going to die on me
but this guy basically he had like
four-wheel records he was an
ultra marathon running i don't know what
it was called but basically has to keep
moving has to be physically active but
this guy was was old school i remember
when you know teaching
the student the students messed up and
you know so i had him on beastie knoll
up and down this this hill i remember
him coming down every time he
come to me you get in the press-up
position i used to feel really
embarrassed like talking
in my granddad please please stand up
captain fox
i said what is it he said can i take my
warm kit off now god
yeah yeah please do but you know really
humbling
being with him but i remember he was in
my group and he's
we were doing the 30 miler next week you
know it's the commando test and the
final test there's a 30 mile
endurance march in eight hours and at
the end you get you covered green beret
he's like he said corporal started he
said is there a grid reference to the
finish point and the finish point
actually is a public car park
on on dartmouth i said yeah you
shouldn't know it but i said this is it
fine so when it came to the 30 miler
i bring him up and so he wanted to know
that did he clarify why
he wanted to know that because he wanted
his wife or whatever yeah he wanted his
girlfriend to come along he said
my girlfriend wants to meet me at the
end do you mind i said yeah fine
so we came over and cut the old man some
slack
yeah yeah much appreciated us older
dudes say yeah right on
thank you yeah i just had so much
respect for him in fact the p
company four years was born so um so i
said yeah of course and then we did the
30 miler and um
on the last phase you bring them up a
hill called poopers hill you come bring
him in
mean you stop them short of the end and
you get them to sort themselves out they
put their
their cap comfort on and you know and we
marched them in
and um so it was doing that and as we
came around the corner
oh my god it was like the super bowl
there was
there no balloons how was that acting i
said i thought it was just your
girlfriend
oh yeah my grandkids as well and my kids
[ __ ]
brilliant i did google uh i think this
is a good section you had in here just
on
on you you touched on it but just the
the attitude of being an instructor you
say
i think a lot of ncos came into their
positions on courses and
and at units thinking that being shouty
shouty and swearing was the way to
behave because that's how it had been
for them
and perhaps they thought it made them
feared
personally i didn't want to scare people
into learning if they didn't want to be
there they'd end up failing themselves
without me shouting and screaming i
found it far more effective to use
humor and to be quiet at times when
others would shout
using that old old parents line of i'm
not angry i'm just disappointed
just a look would be enough they wanted
the approval of those already wearing
the green
lid and so if they saw that they had
failed you
they double their efforts on the next
task no need for shouting or swearing
when you fill a void with swearing it
looks rightly or wrongly
like it's down to lack of intelligence
or to anger issues
instructors were being assessed by their
students just as much as the other way
around
i always decided early on that i would
have that i would share in any
punishment that i handed out
if i gave them press ups then i'd get
down in the mud and do them too not only
did that earn their respect but it gave
them no excuse in their minds to feel
hard done by
at the end of the course those that
earned the coveted berets would be
serving alongside me
and so i wanted to treat them as my
equals even if i was in a position of
authority
especially if i was in a position of
authority
we needed each other and that's the same
whether you're on a training exercise in
combat or attempting a world record
no person is an island
yeah good a great uh attitude that i
think a lot of people
could use you know from a leader not
just instructor but from just a
leadership perspective
you know that you you think maybe you
need to yell to get someone's respect
no it doesn't you actually lose respect
when you act like that
you get done with that and now
you go to see the careers management
officer
and he's asking you about what you want
to do next now did he did he chime in
about
selection about did you see the one that
brought up
you possibly going to selection or did
you already have it in your mind
i had it in my mind so he he pulled me
in so the whole period of time now from
joining five nine to where i was now i
was now a sergeant i'd spent
eight years in five nine and that's
purely because of the record troop the
all-arms commander course
so normally in in the military you spend
three years and then you move on to
another unit you know you progress in
your career
so to have eight years there and seven
and then with brigade record
it's unheard of so i basically had to
move on so i put my paperwork in
for for pathfinders which was the
brigade recce for the airborne unit
and we each year we have a confidential
report and
my report was excellent and he pulled me
in he said can you not see the wood
through the trees he goes you need to go
to then come back as the the wreckage
staff sergeant
going you know pathfinders isn't the way
so you're probably like yeah give me a
bit of a rollicking um but that
afternoon
actually um i got a phone call from
glasgow glasgow runs all our manning
and records they tell you where you're
getting posted and things like
and so the engineer royal engineer
divers we also have
royal navy search divers there have been
a few deaths recently
in the royal navy divers um just purely
because they're not full-time divers and
there's you know lack of
um you know i would say lack of uh
protocol
yeah exactly yeah protocol training so
unfortunately in a couple of deaths
but then hse had now started creeping
into diving you know when i
said earlier that there's no no voice
comms and things like that now you can't
dive unless you've got two-way
visual camera and voice comps hsc was
really creeping into middle school wait
what's hsc health and safety executive
okay yeah yeah yeah the the big banners
so they'd introduced a new dive
equipment called the sabre mod one
um and so it didn't disrupt
the other diving courses they introduced
another dive team to come in
and train all the current divers within
the engineers
so i just passed my army diving
supervisors and got top students so
you know that that same day to start
majors i haven't been moroccan i didn't
get posted to the dive school
so it was out of both our hands um so i
went down as the the senior dive
instructor
um and then you're down there as a
senior drive instructor and it sounds
like
you guys are basically just uh partying
a lot
because in the book i mean you guys are
divers but you kind of it's plenty
you're training
people that are already divers right
yeah yeah and you're just training them
on a new piece of gear
that's it yeah they're already qualified
divers but for them they're going to
portsmouth it's like probably coming to
san diego you know
you've got two weeks in the gaslamp you
know for these guys they're saving up
their money
so ready to rock and roll yeah but every
two weeks you get
another another of qualified divers so
for them it was a holiday they knew that
they knew they were passing they were
just going through the procedures
so they're on holiday and they're
dragging you on holiday yeah
yeah you're coming out and i you know i
was single guys yeah of course
and at one point at what point did you
realize
did you decide you're gonna go selection
so uh a couple of mates have
gone uh sas and we we met up about three
months later
and um you know it really opened my eyes
and
i you know i i like to party hard
and they're all like you're not even
drunk and you know i said
i'm going to go on selection and it was
one of the backflip no you weren't i
said yeah well
so that monday i just stopped drinking
and then and then i trained
um i went on i had an attempt at
selection
before that a couple years before not
long after the alarms command of course
and my knee blew out
on the hill how deep into selection were
you on that first time when you got
blown out me within the aptitude phase
the first
four weeks uh on on the hill train so i
tore my i tore my lateral meniscus
but my training for that selection i was
up and down the north devon coastal path
you know carrying weight i was just
pounding and pounding the knee
so for me i didn't want to have that
same approach with this attempt
also i was running uh dive courses at
the time so any time i had
you know off was the evening so i'd
spend two hours on
on these spin bikes you know these spin
might be on a spinner
for two hours each night uh for six
weeks
how was uh when you when you got dropped
from selection the first time around
like you're kind of making it like it's
no big deal i only know from my
experience it's a when you if
if people don't make it through like
basic seal training yeah
it's a it's a it's horrible because
you're going to be in the regular navy
and that's not what you do in the navy
to do and all of a sudden you're doing
this other thing
or you're doing like a regular navy job
and that's not good and i can't even
fathom
like my mindset if i wouldn't have made
it
but it seems like it's a little easier
on someone that's
you know you're so you were were you at
five nine so i was in record
at the yeah so you're in recce troops
you're like okay i didn't get through it
this time and i still have an awesome
job
so maybe it wasn't quite as
psychologically devastating
yeah well we we you you get two attempts
at selection you see
i knew i had another tape it wasn't the
be all be all or end all but i learned a
lot
from that and it was it was the approach
to training you know
a lot you know we have the first four
weeks which we'll talk about soon on
selection which is the aptitude phase
which is the hills phase
which is the physical once you're at
once you pass that it's when the
uh then comes in and i sort of knew i
just needed to get past that first four
weeks because soldiering-wise
you know i spent years in wrecking troop
you know i was on the all-arms team you
know i was quite current
so when i approac did it the second time
like i said i was on the spinner bike
for two weeks so it was
low impact and um actually i'd we do a
a run in the uk minutes called bft the
basic fitness debt it's
it's a run for a mile and a half and i
got my fastest run at the age of 28 i
didn't like seven minutes 10 seconds
so i thought right you know the fitness
finish fitness is up
up here so i then went on selection
i decided to um
to go sbs i went and did the
they do a thing called a briefing course
because there's two attempts at
selection
days of old guys you know if you weren't
from the marines in paris guys would go
on selection
and get caught out there they'd get big
culture shock they didn't realize
actually what was involved and what
training and preparation you needed to
do so rather than
wasting one life then coming back and
potentially getting injured
both units then introduced a thing
called a briefing course which you can
have
as many attempts at as you want and it's
a one-week course and basically it's
like an aptitude
it gives you an insight of what where
you are fitness-wise
navigation-wise did you get to do that
the first attempt that you did they
didn't have it yet they didn't have that
yet
so you had wasted one life so i'd wasted
one life yeah so i went and did the sas
breathing course
for a week and then the following week i
went and did the sbs one because i still
wanted to
i wanted to make my decision but
obviously
a lot more my friends were in the sas
and i sort of knew all them and you know
saw the way
that they operated and then i went down
to paul endorse it on our south coast
and then and the guys are there you know
they've got
frog shorts t-shirts they've got you
know reef sandals and oakland
yeah this is me this is this is where
this is where i belong
um so i did both and then you have to
make the decision before you go on
selection so i said right
i'm going and that was a new thing
before if you were in the army you're
going the sas if you were in the marines
or i guess would they take regular navy
dudes into the sbs
there's only ever been one navy guy pass
although it's the naval special forces
only only one navy guys pass it up until
then there's 100
um royal marines so normally
you or in the past you would have been
sas 100 percent
not even a choice that's you're in the
army you're going to the sas and at some
point
during the joint environment of hey we
all need to work together yeah
they said pick which one you want to go
to you saw the
you saw the you saw a pool you saw
flip-flops
yeah surf shorts and oakleys and said
i'm i'm heading there yeah that was it
the so
what it was was the marines could go to
the sas
so the marine the sbs we're losing
candidates to the sas
because not everyone likes diving you
see oh yes yeah and then some guys have
head injuries as well it means they
can't go underwater so they're losing
uh students to that and so they decided
to then open up try service that the
navy the army in the raf can come
and they'd just literally just done that
so for me having spent
eight years in free commander brigade
having the green beret anyway
and being to see india it just seemed
the natural transition
the perfect transition for me but in my
head i thought well if i go sas
you know because i'm a senior dive
instructor i'm going to end up in boat
troop
if i go sbs these guys are all divers so
you know i'm a level playing field
and that was where my mindset was and so
yeah i did it much to the disgust of my
friends in the sas
they're like what you're doing because
especially like wrecking tree we had 100
pass rate and it was like you know if
this guy goes then
you know people are gonna look at those
options um
you know uk special forces 40 the uk
special forces made up of the royal
marines that's because they were all
in the sbs you you uh
had to explain this a lot here's the
here's the book
talking to your instructors why the [ __ ]
do you want to go to pool
one of the dss asked me the special
forces selection encompassed all those
who want to go to sas and sbs so it's
the exact same training
you're going to go through the exact
same training the exact same selection
course i should say
i knew i shouldn't give him a real
answer i didn't want to go to boat troop
in hereford
and i liked the way the sbs guys cut
about in t-shirts
shorts and oakley's as a surfer that
appealed to me
and poole would certainly put me closer
to the surf spots of devon and cornwall
i love diving staff [ __ ] answer who
likes diving the ds snorted picking up a
rock
put that in your kit and you better
[ __ ] have it when we're when we get
to the end of the day
i had it with me every day each morning
the ds would ask me the same question
and each day i'd be told to put a rock
into my already heavy bergen
then one day i had an idea my chances of
being the gray man were long gone
and so i decided to deploy a bit of
humor back in the camp
that evening i got busy and in the
morning i was prepared one of two of the
ds walked over to me they were both from
hereford and both had been at five nine
they had a keen eye for horrible rocks
oh you
why the [ __ ] you want to go to pool i
placed my weapon down across my boots
that it was out of the dirt
and opened up the one of the map pockets
in my trousers
pulling out a laminated photo what the
[ __ ] is this one of them sneered
it was a fold it was a photo of born
mouth am i saying that right
bournemouth born mouth got him in
america
it was a photo of bournemouth beach
during a heat wave
i'd pulled it off of google and
laminated it in the office
you don't get topless girl girls on the
beach in hereford staff
i told them with a straight face and
both men burst out laughing
i kept the photo in my pocket for the
rest of the course and didn't carry
another rock
uh actually one of the main reasons why
i do well
i grew up surfing too yeah in in the
cold water of
new england and i was looking at you
know when i was trying to figure out
what i wanted to go into
and one of the things that was seemed
like
a really good deal was either being
stationed in virginia beach which is
good waves on the east coast and or san
diego which is
san diego and either that you know are
you going to
fort bedding or fort lewis or just
there's some
other places to get stationed so that
definitely helped
guide me in the right direction and i
didn't know any seals at the time
otherwise i would have seen
sandals shorts and oakleys and that
probably would have steered me even more
in that direction um
continue on here despite the rocks i did
really well on the hills the training on
the spin bike worked out my joints felt
fresh
on my last basic fitness test at dive
school i even ran my fastest time ever
28 years old avoiding injury on the
hills is key
there's no time for recovery if you get
hurt you're done that's that
and so i was pleased that i'd learned
the lessons of my first attempt at
selection and adapted my plan
accordingly
yeah my buddy john dudley is a bow
hunter and like
he's he spends a bunch of time on the
stationary bike getting ready for
hunting season
and i i was like
i just put on a rock and walk because
i'm maybe not as smart
but yeah it seems like that's a seems
like that works yeah
i think obviously you're gonna have the
impact anyway you know for for me when i
did the first selection you know i've
got quite big
hill legs so actually ascending hills
was not a problem where you need to be
making up your time
is on the on the downhills and on the
straights and you know and that's where
i need
needed to improve so that's that's why i
introduced the spin bike because i
didn't want to
inflame that injury again i didn't want
to you know put starting it in a bad
position so i just looked at
what worked and what didn't you know i
knew i was struck i had the strength
you know in my legs i just didn't have
the speed and how was i going to be able
to improve on that and that's where the
spinning bike was was
perfect for it but the our our aptitude
our first four weeks is you know it's
20 20 to 30 kilometers you know up to 70
pounds
uh you you have then then have like the
test week um
and they say you know you need to be
moving at 4k an hour which thinks
that's fine but that's as the crow flies
looking at a map so if you've got a
mountain in the way
you need to get over that mountain so
you need to really be moving about five
to six k
an hour because if you then have any
issues navigational wise
you know you've got some fudge and you
you're not scraping in
but groundhog day for four weeks doing
that on the
brecon beacons in wales is uh and you
don't
know there's no like cut off time they
just tell you to go
and get it done as quick as you can
that's it yeah you basically get to your
your start point you know the ds will
give you your grid reference you you
then
step aside work out you know which
direction you're going tell him
in time speed distance and you start
working on your 4k an hour how long it's
going to take you
and then you go and then you get to the
next checkpoint which is the top of the
hill where he's always meet the ds
telling me to pick up a rock
and then they will just give you the
next one and you just keep going until
you get to
to the finish point and they also have a
couple of little games in there as well
where you
you think you've finished for the day
and they'll write your next checkpoint
and then you know you go you start going
and
it caught a couple of guys out there
they're done and didn't realize that
actually
it was just the test um you just have to
be
self-disciplined you know self-motivated
yeah no you wrote
you wrote about that in the book how
they'd come up you think you're done
yeah you've been walking for what 12
hours 14 hours or whatever it is
19th day in a row yeah you come up to
the
to the drill sergeant and you say um you
know him checking in and he's like yep
here's your next point
yeah and guys would say i'm done and
they'd quit
yeah and then someone else would come up
and say
they'd say here's your next point they'd
start walking say hey just kidding come
back and then that guy would realize
that they just quit for no reason yeah
yeah i think it was on ours it was a lot
of the parallax a lot of the parachute
regiment lads would go
as drivers to drive the vehicles on the
selections before so they knew
the start and finishes points and it was
actually to catch them out because
in their head they're like right i've
just got 30 kilometers i've just got 30
kilometers
and so they built themselves up and when
they get to that point they think it's
finished and then when you throw a
little curveball in there to like they
weren't expecting it
um but then yeah even test week you know
it's called the aptitude phase but test
week itself you then have
five marches and if you don't come in on
the times
you know you get a red card you get two
red cards uh you're done i think the
first three march is about
30 kilometers the fourth march is it's
35 kilometers
but then you have four hours rest and
then that evening you do 40 miles
uh with 70 pounds it's called endurance
and you have to do that within 20 hours
it's called other things besides
endurance
yeah yeah so um but you finish that and
you think brilliant you know i've i've
just passed the hills phase
it's quite a big thing but for the
instructors they're called aptitude
they don't even call you by your name
they don't even know who you are at this
point it's like
and you probably lost 50 percent of the
course at this point either voluntary
withdrawal
injury or actually just not meeting the
injury level's got to be high yeah
because that's a beat down on your
joints oh i mean well it happened to you
the first time
yeah exactly i mean even obviously like
i
i broke my ankle as a young boy so my so
my nemesis in the military was my my
left ankle
and so it would go over we can edit that
out we don't want everyone to know his
weaknesses so for me though i knew that
and i would take
you know i'd take my ankles up and
things like that and i remember on test
week
um i had these these military boots
lowers had great ankle support
because you know because lads were were
failing they were leaving so in the
evening
you put your boots in the drying room
and i remember going in the next day and
i'm like
they look a bit small and one of the
guys who left had taken my boots
and i was like oh no i still had three
more test marches with these with these
almost like jungle boot style boobs you
know running across all these babies
heads so uh
yeah but you know it's also
administering yourself and looking after
yourself and
prevention
um you continue on
you get past that that phase and like
you say in here like
that was just the beginning um and you
also say this you had to be totally
self-motivated you
had the mental strength or you didn't
unlike p company or command of course
there were no shouts of encouragement
from the staff
anything the ds did say would be an
attempt to undermine your confidence
make you second-guess
yourself my preparation for the course
helped a lot i never doubted my
decisions
i knew i'd done the work over the years
to be spot on with my map and compass
i knew i'd left enough sweat in the gym
to have my fitness up to standard
i'm only human and i'd listen to the ds
as
cutting criticism but then i could
calmly say to myself it's just part of
the mind games mate you're doing fine
times like those i think back to when my
dad had told me i wouldn't last two
minutes in the army he'd been wrong
and so would the ds
yeah they play they they learn what to
say to people
to get them to quit you know they they
say all kinds of things
and what you would you say right there
uh it's just part of the mind games yeah
but man they go hard
yeah yeah they do yeah we we we go to
the jungle so one once we finish the
hills phase we
we start doing some uh some inventory
skills as well because basically
you're learning all over again so
whether you're a marine or para
the way that they operate in uk sf is
totally different and you're introducing
new weapon systems
so the c8 demarco is only used by uk
special forces you're having to learn a
whole new weapon system
uh again and um yeah but
you know from your friends who've done
it before you that they're gonna start
playing mind games with you and i
remember
we go to brunei spend six weeks in the
jungle and that's that's a great
great part selection you lose a lot of
guys there you know some guys really
thrive in the jungle and some guys it's
almost like um
it's claustrophobic you know you spend a
lot of time in their day in day out and
hear the helicopter coming in to pick up
the lads and you see guys it's just see
guys randomly packing their bags
like jesus and they're like what you're
doing they said oh well you know i'm
gonna fail this instructor said it was
like ignore what the instructor said
but i remember when it happened to me i
remember we were marching
up to a um a range and everything we do
on selection is live firing we don't do
blank
everything is for real um you know
because on a data race you don't fire
blank
and it's all about weapon handling that
you're safe but you know effective
and i remember one instructor is coming
straight up to me [ __ ] in my face
screaming and shouting
if i see any weapon handling like that
again because you'll be off
you'll be on the next helicopter and i
just said yes stuff
um i didn't get into an argument i
hadn't even been on the range yet he
didn't realize that you know i hadn't
been on the range i knew
it was my day uh that he was testing me
and you you could see it as well you
know throughout the course you can see
oh
he's getting it today the instructor
would be on you i mean
you get guys you know who don't pass and
they said oh yes because i had
a personality clash with the instructors
and a lot of them tend to use that
but what they do on selection which is
great is actually especially the final
exercise the last 10 days they swap your
instructors around
so if there is you know human beings
there's always going to be personality
crashes if there is anything like that
it's sort of
you get you get a fair chance at it so
um but i enjoyed i enjoyed
the jungle for me um you know i was
going through
a court case at the time my ex-wife and
trying to get custody of my
my first daughter and um i remember
passing and we have a barbecue and they
always say don't go on selection with
any welfare issues you need to go there
fully focused you know so guys guys
would get letters
from their wives you know blueys and
she's having a bad day
you know if she's at home with a friend
would you call it a bluey bluey it used
to be like blue
uh blue envelopes which are free free
posts
um and you know you write in there and
it's purely just military so it's known
as a bluey
and you know if your wife's having a bad
day and she's got kids and
she thinks you're on holiday in brunei
you know i mean um and she's like
i mean you know plays your mind and guys
pull themselves off
and then phone their wives and i'm
actually all right now you know what i
mean so they do say
just cut off all the white noise so when
i finish my uh
my chief instructor is like because hi
here guys come on here we're well
i said i'm going through a divorce and
custody of my kid is it really
i said the only place the solicitors
can't get letters to me
and that's i mean so for me at the time
it was it was a big escape
escape
i got back in this big pile of letters
that are great but um
but yeah you come back from that and
i i got the uh troop sergeant role for
the final five days of the of the final
attack and
you saw that's almost an indicate that
you you're doing well um so i sort of i
knew i'd done well on the course but
when you come out the jungle you have
the barbecue the instructors
get together they have their little you
know final decisions
but you don't know for another five days
when you get back to uk
they don't they don't tell you there and
then it's like so you know
one of the instructors came up to me at
the barbecue a friend of a friend
uh south african land and drunk totally
drunk he's out yeah you've done well i
said
but you should come and say yes so it's
almost like you've been given the nod
unofficially and so you're telling lads
you've been given a nod yeah i haven't
so lads are self-critiquing over the
next five days
and and a member the same ds came up to
me the next day so
he said story he said did i give you the
nod last night i said no he said
did you pass i said i didn't know you
said i did i said oh
i was drunk i was gonna say that's like
psychological
yeah all kinds of psychological gains
hey it's been nice knowing you've
really made good effort out here yeah
but
actually the the jungle drums it's quite
a big thing selection you know
those instructors will go back they'll
sort of tell things it doesn't take long
before it starts so i got a text of my
friend's wife saying well done
you've passed how does this wife know in
devon
i'm back but even though you you're
feeling confident that you've done it
you still you still when you walk in
five days later
it's like you know because occasionally
guys are getting the down
check because whatever yeah that's it
you know they may have got through the
jungle phase but it may be like
not not this time but with the jungle
you only get one attempt
so that that's your only attempt so yeah
that's a that's quite a big
big color as well but once you've
finished the jungle phase
you know that they want you you know so
the next three months
you know unless you're a real you know
do a neil diamond negligent
negligent discharge or something like
that you're
you you should be safe and what's the
last three months what are you doing for
that section
so you do continuation chains to do sear
it's a vital evasion resistance
extraction
uh running through gray coats around
scottish highlands
um you do your your parachute and your
squares you do
communications kit and then the final
phase counter terrorism
um so basically they they get you into a
position that when you join your saber
squadrons
that you can fit into the team but you
you that's just your start point within
the squadrons but
so it's a six month process it's
actually quite
long drawn out and we we
basically the sbs and sas as you touched
on is joint
selection and the accommodations at
hereford with the ses and you're seeing
the guys on the course
already been given you know what
squadron they're going to told what
deployments are going having to go see
the quartermaster to get kit and you
guys in the sps are like oh my god
you know not getting anything um so it
is quite frustrating that they get their
berry and belt
and then we used to just get given a
blue track so you've got then another
three months continuation
oh it's it's it continues on it it does
it is
still selection or is it just
continuation it's
days of old it used to be selection
because if you failed the dive course
they'd
accept you in the sas so you know the
whole thing you know what's the
difference in the ses in the sbs are you
always a surprisingly avid soldier
slightly better soldier you know sort of
joking but um
you know but but actually they then
introduced that we then got we then got
our own sort of
unit recognition we got our own cat
badge recently and
you know we got our own belt because
days of old you wouldn't know
who was sbs because it was a raw marine
cap badge that was it yeah the only
indicator was this is long curly hair
um
you go here an elite club it may have
been and the journey to get there was
incredibly difficult but
all of the other men at the squadron i
now joined had done exactly the same
so no one remarked on it for me
selection been the most monumental thing
in my life
but for these guys it was a tick in the
box to get me to work
you the new guy are you all right
simple as that i'd be the the exactly
the same way once i'd spent some time at
pool
and the next cadre of new guys came in
but for now i was the new bloke
and i was about to begin one of the most
intense periods of my life what year is
this
so this is 2006. oh okay so it's on
so when where were you when september
11th happened so september 11th i
we were about to go on a uh an exercise
called safe zaria
in oman it was a big big exercise i
remember
obviously seeing the twins i was you
know getting pulled into the cinema
watching it
and then that um that afternoon i got a
phone call from the dive school
saying that you know there's an army
advanced diving course started yesterday
yesterday one of the guys has failed his
his entrance test
so our diving courses are in phases you
have the basic course which is
um which is six weeks
you had advanced courses 10 and you your
supervisor so you have to pass each
before you progress
and so i got a phone call to come down
to dive school
so i was heading down the road and then
obviously see the twin towers everyone's
going to oh man i think oh my god i'm
going to miss out
on this and you know so i missed the
initial the initial phases
and then i was at limston on the
training team when the lads lads
deployed so yeah i i missed out with
free commander rigging
my afghan tour so i was fuming fuming so
my my first deployment afghan was yes
with the sbs
[Music]
uh you say here um i totally understand
that some people will be disappointed
that i can't divulge
details of special forces operations but
our country has enemies and we can't
hand them
information that could endanger the
lives of my former colleagues who
continue to operate around the world
selflessly providing the blanket of
freedom beneath which we sleep
i know you'll appreciate that and in
light of what they sacrifice we can
sacrifice some stories
let me just say that those years gave me
some of my best friends
and that i love the job so this is now
you're you're going on deployments
um with the sbs and
obviously we're not going to go into any
any details of them
were you guys primarily doing like
direct action
yeah so when we i was very fortunate my
first you know i'd missed that
opportunity free commander brigade so
when i went out with the sbs
um my first our first deployment was the
first ever operational jump for the sbs
into into hellmann so i was at wow it's
my first time in afghan and it's an
operational jump
at night um so yeah we we were doing
it's called task force
42 tf-42 which is the door kicking but
also
alongside that um the intelligence
services were also
picking up agents and things that so i
was having to work between
between both normally the instructor the
guys who would go on that were from our
reservists and it all failed the course
so when i first got there it was
literally door kicking at night and then
in the day dressing up as a local
um but for me we then did numerous
operational jumps we were very fortunate
on that tour we had the most hvts
and any squadron and we had more hvts
in first three months than the last
three squadrons back to back
um because we were just changing the way
that that we operated
as you know out there you had to change
you know they all knew your ttps and you
had to
change and adapt to that so for me it
was i was at the pinnacle you know i'd
missed out that time of free commander
ago but
i i made up for it in abundance and
what's your position are you
are you like a breacher are you a sniper
what's your
what's your role yeah so actually one
thing i forgot to mention so unlike
um so when i went on selection i was a
sergeant when you finish selection
your rank goes you start again as a
trooper as a trooper
yeah well actually they said i was gonna
be a marine i was like oh i said
i said that's fine but know that no
other army lad especially airborne is
going to come in
to sbs if you call us marines you have
to call us troopers
so when i went there i was almost like
the guinea pig you know what works what
doesn't work and
and things like that so yeah but then
you do were you literally the first
army there was two two other guys with
uh two other guys with me there was an
officer and another engineer lad
in your selection class yeah and so you
three
were the first army soldiers to go into
the i think there was one before there
was one
one before us but uh first time in in
this squadron
but from the engineers especially
wreckage we've been being the first and
i think now
15 of the sbs is now made up of the army
so it was almost like the floodgates
had opened um which i think is good
because the marines as i said they're so
proud of
you know their background i think that
but you need diversity you need
diversity in there and that's what the
army
the army brought in also the fact that
at the time the sas were run in iraq
and the sbs would run in afghanistan so
again you know for guys who want to go
on selection you know iraq was starting
to wind down
you know guys were looking uh towards
afghans so the sbs was a good option
there
yeah that's my interaction with well i
had two
interactions with the with the british
special forces in my career
one of them was before 9 11 and
it was very cool and i'll tell you about
it later and then the other one was um
it was it was just in in iraq you know
we were hitting target sets and
there was like multiple targets that
were all somehow connected
and so i just sat down next to the troop
commander and we
talked through the plan and really good
guy and obviously just
you know when people ask me about the
the brits and i've
i've worked with other british units but
all of them what i say about the brits
the british are just professionals
like just professionals the way they
behave the way they operate
it's just always awesome you know
they're going to be squared away it's um
that was always my impression of
of the british special forces and of the
british military in general
yeah except for one person that i'll
tell you also tell you about later
which was really strange and he was
british navy so which is strange right
because that's the royal navy that's the
rule navy yeah right yeah we should be
just totally squared away yeah well
that's probably where the drinking
drinking the problems are yeah this guy
was
uh i don't know maybe he could have used
a beer at this particular ritual
uh so you so i cut you off when you were
talking about i'd asked you were you a
sniper
yeah yeah so when you when you joined um
it depends
so we have four troops um so you have
air mountain boat
and mobility i mean you go in there and
as i said when you when you pass
selection you think i've just done six
months you know
you're at the the you're baseline and
now another bass line and you have to
then get all these other skill sets so
within the teams it's where there's any
gaps or whether it's language
demolitions you know i was the forward
air controller so mine was anything to
do with air
uh was me so i was i was the fac within
art
and then that means you get to go on
every mission yeah exactly yeah
yeah perfect but then you obviously
stacking up on the doors you know
you would be point man you know there's
guys out there who've got books like
first man in i'm the leader
well you're not you know the first man
in is is the new boy you know the
the section commander or the commander
is like number three or four
so but then obviously when you bounce on
to the next door it just depends who was
there you know that's what we used to do
you know we didn't really have say right
we have to go in this order
you know when we did our training it was
unrelenting you know
we knew it inside out the drills it was
just second nature
very slick so uh but you were
so you're just you guys are doing a
rolling point doesn't matter who goes in
but
did you did you guys have breacher did
you have a special assignment for that
because you're an engineer i figured you
were going to say breacher because we
always kind of associate breacher with
engineer
was that enough yeah no it wasn't
actually when i when i yeah
so out there no no it wasn't because it
because their demolitions is slightly
different from the royal engineer
demolitions i know
we'll take down the bridge not put a
nice little hole in it we know we'd
probably drop the whole compound
things they didn't trust you you'd be
using too much explosives
but what they tend to do which i thought
was great in the special forces if you
already have skill sets
you've already you've already got that
skill set let's give you another skill
set you know so
you sort of build on it so like the
pathfinder lads who
like the airborne recce when they go sas
they're already
halo trained so there's no point in them
going air troop they've got that skill
set put them in boat route you know so
they try and give you as many skill sets
as possible yeah
and then how long would you guys go on
deployments for so ours is six months
six month deployment we used to do a two
year sort of rule month so
six months pre-deployment training six
months training you then come back and
then you're on the green roll so you're
on the pager for any sort of
any other um situations around the world
and then six months counter terrorism
then so hostage rescue
in you know domestic and international
and then um
when you i like like i said i think
that's enough broad
people can kind of figure out what you
were doing um but how long
how many years of this cycle were you on
so this side got discipled every every
two years so every two years you've been
out for
for another six months unless you then
you spend four years
in your saber squadron and then you you
have to move on you then get like an
instructional post
okay so guys tend to do that and then
they then come back in and slot in as
then team leaders
i'm gonna go through the whole room on
again so now we're gonna
jump into one particular
pre-deployment training cycle i'm going
to the book we were in the desert as
part of our pre-deployment training
i couldn't wait to get back out on
operations nor could any of the other
guys
being on ops was the reason we joined
the special forces and nowhere
were our skills put to the test more
than the daily
life or death battles with our enemies
we're going on high altitude high
opening training i loved
jumping jumping some guys didn't and
just sucked it up but i always wanted to
be the first in the stick so i could
stand on the open tail ramp and look
down at the earth beneath me
i wanted to soak it all in before i
jumped but on the second jump that day i
was put in the back of the line
i waddled with my kit toward the door as
the others left the aircraft
one guy tumbled out after the next
eventually it was my turn
i jumped and immediately i knew
that i was in trouble i felt something
on my leg
i looked up and saw that it was wrapped
in rigging
i knew that as soon as the static line
pulled up the canopy
that rigging would shoot up above my
head and the force of it would take my
leg
with it i had a second to get my leg
clear whack i failed
the static line pulled the chute the
chute pulled the rigging
the rigging pulled my leg it came up and
over my shoulder
like i was a yoga guru instantly i felt
every muscle ligament and tendon
rip and snap i screamed in absolute
agony and almost blacked out from the
pain
the rigging worked its way clear and now
the leg fell back alongside the other
but i knew that i had no control over
its movement i was lucky to still have
the leg the force could have easily
ripped it off and if that happened i'd
have bled to death within minutes and
some poor local would have had a
one-legged corpse
landing in his garden pain was racing
through my body
but i knew that if i didn't get my act
together i could still die
i was so far up that oxygen was thin and
i could not afford to pass out i drifted
away from my guys
if i drifted away from my guys i could
end up in the middle of the desert or
the sea it would be browners i had to
stay awake
you'd think that the pain would have
made that easy but it was so intense
that my brain was trying to send me into
unconsciousness
i wouldn't let it i just wouldn't
instead i fixed my focus on the
descending parachutes
of the stick and followed them in it was
the longest 30 minutes of my life
despite the physical agony i had time
had enough time hanging in the sky to
feel
emotional pain too i knew that there
would be no deployment for me now
i think i knew deep down that there
would be no more time on operations at
all
30 minutes is a long time to think about
that when you're alone
floating through the air finally the
ground was getting closer
i saw my mates landing in formation i
wanted to make a good landing out of
pride
but more than that i knew that if i
landed badly i could quite
well ruin my good leg too the ground
came up to meet me
i pushed down on my toggles and flared
the chute just at the right moment
dragging in enough air under the canvas
to take the speed out of my descent
if you do it too early you just stop in
the sky then drop like a sack of [ __ ]
but i came in like a feather and landed
on one leg
there was only one thing left to do
medic
what year was that so that was 2010.
so ma'am um
that's it i mean your leg you did you
know instantly you were you were done
yeah um you know it was actually the new
guys who come to the squadron were
getting hey-ho trained
so our sergeant major we'd already
brought a heiho train from previous
tours he's like
we'll go do fun jumps you know i'd like
jumping but there's no such thing as a
fun jump in the military
and um and the reason i got moved like
normally i'm at the front i like to frog
you know you turn around and you exit
the pgis which used to always upset the
uh
the the raf so i then got moved to the
back of the stick
and like i said we've done numerous of
these jumps just routine but as i exit
it got caught in the line so i'm trying
to kick it in time
and i couldn't and then when it got
pulled up and over you know
you'd probably hear me from the ground
screaming
so but no one else in the team is aware
there's anything
anything going on um but because of
those
thin altitude i was drifting in and out
i was vomiting
because of the pain and i just needed to
get i just wanted to get to the ground
and see and re establish what's what's
going on
um assessed the other parachutists their
approach you know took another
a look over dee's head and landed it
one-legged but
you know straight away i couldn't put
any pressure on it you know because got
uh we got um medic medic uh back to
the camp uh had a mri scan the next day
and i was like yeah you've torn
your acl your mcl your lateral meniscus
your hamstring your calf your quad it's
all the supporting muscles as well so
normally with an acl or mcl
you you can carry on you see rugby
players just carrying on
but it's all the supporting muscles but
to add to the issue as well
the it was the icelandic volcano which
is grounded aircraft all over the world
so they couldn't get an error med to me
so based i was just thrown into a hotel
in muscat the lads went on
to tour from there i was put in a hotel
for four weeks with painkillers
you know sort of deteriorating got back
to uk
after an era med sent home for six weeks
back to the hospital then they'd lost
all my paperwork and it was just a
spiral of
of errors within the military medical
system
how long did it take for you to get
through i mean how long did it take to
get surgery and you talk about in the
book but how long was that it was 44
weeks in the end you know my when i
injured my leg on the first
selection process it was five days i
mean i was running again in six weeks it
took me 44 weeks
to get this so you know my whole my leg
had deteriorated
completely and for me i was then
transitioning to civilian street so i
wasn't really focused on my
my rehab was like what am i gonna do
next did your uh
at what point did did you know did
somebody say hey that's it
you you can't be here anymore do they
offer you medical retirement like what
did that process look like
you'd like to think they'd offer you
medical retirement um but it didn't you
know i had to
almost threaten them that i i needed um
with legal that i needed the operation
and when i
left they the pay scale they put me out
and was one below a medical pension and
it said you were fixed within
26 weeks i was like well it was 44 weeks
so five years later i i had a tribunal
here and against the military
and what the military tend to do is
it's basically guys that appeal it
they'll say no
and you can appeal it again and they'll
say no they'll lose 80 percent of people
doing that so i knew a general who said
to me he said just keep appealing said
they won't even
open your case until it's the third
appeal which is five years later
so that's what i did and then i had a
tribunal hearing in
in edinburgh and i went down and
actually had a qc in front of you and
two doctors
from the military i then brought a
military charity
called the royal british legion and they
just sort of ask certain questions which
gets your story out and then you have a
representative from the military
veterans
appealing you and normally they can be
quite aggressive but this guy was
actually quite
quite relaxed um but someone did say to
me the week before he said look when you
go in this that he goes he
he had one and he didn't get his medical
pension he said when you go in there you
can't be
dean stop special forces you know these
guys say
can you walk down the street you say no
you know it was one of them so i had
that in the back of my mind and
i went in and actually they had the
timeline that i'd printed out
and um you know i then ended up getting
a full
full medical pension and then back dated
but the fact that i had to go through it
with my own yeah it's crazy so you'd
like to think you know especially when
you feel like you're the top again you
feel like you're a pop star we're in you
know tier one special forces and then
just this all
almost put a a cloud over my
my career you know not my career but the
my last
last year in the military yeah it's a
bad it leaves you the bad taste leave me
a bad taste i didn't actually realize
until i was successful how you know what
a weight was on my shoulders you know
one i felt when i got it i felt i'd been
reciprocated for my time
you know things and i could almost close
that chapter and move on but that was
five years after leaving
how many years then did you how many
years were you in total
16. so 16 years in
and so you get what from the day you got
injured
how long did it take before you said all
right i need i'm going to get out
because i can't do my job anymore
so it was over nearly a year and i had
to extend
because i hadn't even been operated on
the military have to return you to
civilian street
in similar condition or best condition
than what you entered and i was nowhere
near that so
so for me my mindset you know my head's
now thinking well i'm not
i'm not in the military anymore i need
to look look beyond that
but you still can't progress because
you're waiting on on this operation so i
i got it in the end and then
when i finally left in may 2011 is when
i actually
got out and then as you're working
through this transition
um at some point you get a call
it's uh can you be in libya tomorrow
yeah
yeah that's it yeah so to add to the
pressure you know
you know when you know we talk about
identity crisis you spent
all this time in the military working in
a tiny knit unit
you know knowing what you're doing day
out working alongside professionals to
like
where do i now fit in society what is my
role what is my purpose
so i had that going on in my head i
hadn't really had
that full transition so guys when
they're getting out they have like two
year build up
you know to do all these workshops and
they set up their companies mine was
almost
you know crash bang you're out the door
my wife at this point was eight months
pregnant
you know so i'm like i gotta say any
work out there you know what i'm gonna
do and without sounding like liam neeson
people with our skill sets tends to be
the private security industry
so this was the middle of the arab
spring and
qadhafi was still in tripoli at this
point and in benghazi a lot of the oil
companies the security companies the
media
were forming up and my friend who was a
director one of the large
security companies said dean can you be
in libya and i said yeah
of course i can't so i went i went
straight in and basically it was a
it was a diffid project department for
institute development which was the
you know at the time was the prime
minister's little baby so
they would go into the these sort of
countries and you'd have representatives
from the the financial sector
from the the medical and you know the
military and it's to basically advise
and help these
these countries get back on their feet
uh
so they're all preparing for qaddafi so
i he said can you go in
can you help set up the diffid project
we're going to fly 30
private security operators in from iraq
and afghanistan
so i went in and straight away
i could see there was no threat you know
the libyans were very hospitable
but they also were quite adamant that
they didn't want this being another
afghanistan
in iraq you know once qadhafi had fallen
and they wanted to take control of their
country they didn't want
you know private security so we had
these mp7s
these weapons and these guys came in two
days later from this herc
you know these herc from afghan in iraq
and like where's our weapons
and that's sort of sort of changing
their mindset that actually there is no
threat and you know it needs to be all
low-key um i was also trying to find
a niche within the industry and i was
looking at all these other security
companies a lot of my friends
had their their security companies were
doing uh anti-piracy off the east coast
of uh africa so i didn't want to tread
on their feet
so some of these big security companies
i identify with charging you know
six figure sums for crisis managements
and evacuation plans but when you
scrape the surface there was nothing in
place
so having spent two weeks set that up i
um
i flew back home and alana gave birth to
our daughter molly
and um i said i think i've got a plan
so i i went back in to libya and
and there was a huge proliferation of
weapons at the time it was actually
ammunition it was difficult to get hold
of so i bought 30 weapons
on the black market and i buried them
between tunas and egypt
i just spent a month in the desert just
caching these pellet cases with
comms kits and money and just wrote my
own evacuation plans hoping
never to really really need them and
that's what i did we lived in aberdeen
which is the
oil and gas capital of europe so i had a
good links to the oil and gas sector and
that's what i did i didn't that was my
niche
i'd found a niche within within the
industry um
so yeah now did you set that up where
you were talking to the oil companies
and i've been to aberdeen thankfully
uh very cool so have you ever surfed
there i i haven't no but i know
up thirsty further north is one of the
great spots i was there in like
the winter and you could have surfed it
like it wouldn't have been fun but
you could have surfed i was looking at
the waves i went for a little run down
there and i was looking at the waves and
i was like well
you could do it yeah you could do it but
we're making not fun
close freezing choppy he's like barely
you could probably surf for about you
know two seconds or three seconds per
wave
you'd have the waves to yourself though
there was no water there was no one even
on the beach
um so did you did you set that
the those all that gear up and then go
and pitch to clients like hey i've got
these plans set up here's what i can do
for you
and then are they giving you some kind
of a revenue up front yeah so
so basically i identified that i wrote
him up first
you know because it's almost like right
i have this plan in place you know
i had the cases so my sort of mindset
with it was i
i knew that the libyans didn't want
security companies
with weapons so before long we couldn't
do that so my sort of mindset was
if there was a situation we could drive
across the border
unarmed you know go to the cage points
pick them up if we need the if we needed
weapons
you know and then and then get you know
decline out and then bury them
that was it so it was almost like a
retainer and knowing that that service
was there um and then we used to have
like
like triggers you know you know if
there's a certain situation we go up to
yellow we go up to amber
so really you should never if if you're
a deer into that trigger system that you
have in place you shouldn't really
need to go full on evacuation the only
thing that sort of
is is natural disasters that's where you
can go from green to red overnight this
is a natural disaster so really if you
have that in place but that's something
i just picked up
from the military um was these cage
systems and these cases that actually
um the ira and the taliban use these
cage systems that's where it originates
um but for me it just wasn't i was
walking around with weapons but i knew
that i had safe houses and i knew there
were weapons available if needed
and you built relationships and you talk
about that a lot in here
yeah yeah you know i sort of you know
i when i got out as well i didn't want
to be going out to afghanistan
and iraq you know i'd done my time in
the dead no
i sort of the security security industry
isn't risk reward
ratio balanced at all you know you could
be in yemen libya or somalia on 50
of what you're on taking the uae royal
family super yacht from barcelona to
maldives so i was at well where's the
money
and it's in the corporate close
protection so i didn't have cargo pants
and
tight tops you know it was like it was a
nice dinner jacket
shirt and brogues and and that was that
was my approach but
everyone has this perception of special
forces you know
it's about offensive action it's you
know breaching walls it's kicking
indoors and things like that that's 25
of what we do 50 of what we do is is
support and influence it's hearts and
minds being embedded
with the locals understanding actually
what is the situation on the ground not
what i'm seeing on tv
but what is actually physically going on
in the ground
so for me i really built up good
relationships with local fixers
there's 167 tribes in libya so my fixer
in tripoli
isn't my same fixer in benghazi so i
quickly understood that especially
during that
that arab spring and i just returned
from
the london olympics i was providing
security for visa
and i was in benghazi the evening that
your american ambassador got killed
um september 11 2012. and i
i got a phone call could i escort help a
german
oil company eight german engineers get
them out of benghazi
so while it was all i think they made a
film 13 hours but it was all kicking off
in the city
i got these guys safely from benghazi to
tripoli through safe houses that i had
in the desert
and again i remember we had drivers from
benghazi
and we got to the safe house and we
could you know we could drive to tripoli
in a day
but i said no we'll wait here for 48
hours which was worrying the engineers a
bit
and the benghazi guys had like big big
beds and they're like
oh no mr dean we can go i said no no we
wait 48 hours
but they were nervous i knew they were
nervous going into tripoli
because they're from the wrong region um
but what they weren't aware of as i was
getting drivers
coming in from tripoli to meet us and
they would carry on
um it's that sort of knowledge knowing
who to use
and when to use and i remember the
morning we were leaving and these poor
guys and benghazi because i couldn't
tell them they'd shaved all their bits
and then i just went outside and the
tripoli drivers had turned up it was
like a
almost like a scene from the okay corral
they all started going for their weapons
i said look
i said i cannot take you to tripoli you
will compromise
us these guys can do it and i said look
you will still get paid and it's just
all about respect you know i
i always say about communication but for
that operation i couldn't
i couldn't uh divulge too much to them
so i got them safely out and then
two years later i was in um brazil
for visa again covering the world cup
and i then get a phone call from the
canadian embassy
so what happened now is the tripoli war
it's a civil war between the militias
and the government
and embassy is the the only reason
embassies are in countries is all about
trade and investment you know what can
we get for for our country you know when
it
when things start opening up so october
13
the um they've done an assessment the
canadians and basically
it was costing them 20 million dollars a
year to have the embassy open
and their sort of assessment was there's
gonna be no trade investment for about
at least 15 years
so when we see a window of opportunity
let's
collapse the embassy and leave but they
couldn't just collapse them because the
locals would be questioning them
so fast forward now of summer 14 the
tripoli war the americans the brits
italians they just shut shot
and when the canadians aren't going back
so they had to shred everything and stay
there
their protection team was canadian
military
and they would fly in every four months
rotate you know fly into tripoli
international airport
but during their period of four months
they never left
the walls of tripoli they just went from
their accommodation to the office it
didn't
get out the city so they didn't know
what was beyond the city walls and it's
actually only 100 kilometers coastal
road from tripoli
to tunis so i flew in and
we'd already evacuated a couple of
people from usaid
and i i did i don't go with the big over
vehicles like local taxis
just keep it all low profile and
the week before the british got engaged
at every checkpoint
on the way to um to tunis which was
obviously worrying the the canadians
so me and my fixer um we went out
and we just rather than speaking to the
guys who got the weapons you know
identified who the tribal elders was
sat down with him no shared bread showed
coffee and it was actually all about
communication showing them respect and
um
yeah the following following day they
then escorted us
safely so i've got 18 military and four
diplomats
single-handedly from tripoli to
to tunis yeah just to put that in
perspective a little bit when i was a
young seal before
before you know um september 11th
one of the main missions i did two
deployments with the marine corps
on ships and one of the main missions
that we would train for
is called uh a neo non-combatant
evacuation operation
which is literally to go into whatever
am you know an american embassy
presumably
and go in in some hostile or
semi-hostile country and evacuate those
people but they would have
an entire amphibious ready group with
you know several battalions of marines
the air support
the seals all to go and get whatever
that group is out of the country so
when i was reading that portion of the
book where you made this happen that's a
that's a huge
deal to do this essentially a mission
that normally
uh that could utilize an entire
amphibious ready group with
airframes and ships and the whole nine
yards to make this happen
and you're able to do it um in a
different
from a different angle by utilizing the
locals by
having building relationships with the
locals going and doing it low profile
that's just a it's a real credit to the
way you were thinking about that
operation
yeah you have to think out of the box
you know the fish wagons there's fish
wagons that take
fish from tripoli to tunis every day so
we used the fish wagons to put the
equipment in
because they would just go straight
through border control
they were a bit slower getting to tunis
and i could see the canadians getting
getting a bit a bit worried but yeah it
was just thinking
thinking out the box we did have uav
coverage there was uav coverage to
to the border and then when we were at
the border the canadians are met
but i did that job um for free
and the reason i did that was the year
before i just finished the
uh well i mean go ahead it's it's
it's an interesting perspective um good
you you you got yourself into a
situation
yeah that maybe didn't give the best
image
of what you were trying to do yeah so my
role within the security industry i was
very ad hoc you know when i got out a
lot of my friends went over to work in
the uae
and trained their military um which is
great good money and things out but i
wanted to learn more
you know outside that military
environment as well i actually did more
sensitive jobs
as a private secure operator than i did
when i was in the special forces
and you know i worked all over africa
yemen you know
every time i got a phone call it was a
different country it was a different job
and i just come out of yemen
and i was in dubai and i got a phone
call from
my friend we just set up a new company
in london and he said can you be
can you be in libya tomorrow i said well
i can't my visas expired
so don't worry about that this is a
different call by the way i did that
quote earlier did you
can you be can you be in libya libya
tomorrow this is another time that that
happened this is another time
this was what this is what you were
doing once you got out of the military
you're running these
security events you're providing
security you're doing assessments you're
doing
evacuations and so this is another time
when you got the call hey can you be in
libya tomorrow
yeah can you be in libya tomorrow and i
was out well no because my visas expired
and he said
you don't need a visa i was at fine so
uh we flew via manchester flew straight
in and i i got to the um
i got to the airport terminal this young
guy comes up to me said
you mr dean i said yeah mr dean said
follow me so everyone's in the queue for
passports and we went in another queue
and um we went to took me into the city
and went to the te bestie hotel
uh which is uh part of the cramfey hotel
group but i knew that was owned by the
maltese and also by the government
and one of the guys that he said right
met my one of my partners there my
business partners
and he said right you're just about to
go meet the prime minister of libya he
speaks
no english speaks german so the health
minister is going to translate
i was okay fine so a bit a bit boring on
the backstory about 48 hours before
the militias had seized all the oil
terminals to stop exporting of oil in
libya
and so we went upstairs and he sits down
he explains his situation to me
and um he says what do we do
and i said well i said what do you want
he said i want i want terminals back
the terminals back i said look well we
can
we can pull a team together you know do
four four simultaneous assaults you
don't want to do back to back because
you're warning four simultaneous
assaults either from sea or from land
but leave the flank open from to escape
said no i don't want to escape and i
sort of looked over to my friend
um and he said this has been sanctioned
oh not really
so okay so let me just translate this
for people that might not be tracking
so there's oil um rigs that have been
seized
the prime minister of libya is sitting
there telling you
i want these things back from these
insurgents or
whatever you want to call them i want
these oil rigs back from these
insurgents
i want you to do a simultaneous where
you said hey i can do a simultaneous
assault yeah so you're going to need a
lot of people to do this
and then you say listen you know smart
thing you're thinking hey i'll give them
a way to get out so that way they're not
going to stand and fight hopefully and
you know we'll we'll mitigate damage and
he says no
we don't want anyone to escape we want
you to go and kill all these people that
are
on these oil rigs and that's so that's
the
the mission tasking that you're getting
okay so that's the mission task and and
for the listeners so basically in libya
benghazi
over in the east is where all the oil is
and the the
politicians are all in the west and
again different tribes they do not get
on well
so and then in the middle you've got
misrata as well and they're just
so there's a big mess so i walked out
this meeting and on that
right i'm gonna need at least 150 guys
you know 50 tier 1 and 70 tier 2.
and this was being funded he said yeah
make it happen
so straight away so i'm like i'm having
to make phone calls
and i would love to see the invoice on
this that you're going to send
but and it was no the money we were
getting for this
job was four times your normal daily
wage
you know and so i i had guys on standby
in uk
on like twice as much they're doing in
in iraq and an afghan just staying at
home
it was huge it started to grow in into a
beast and every evening i would go up
and speak to the prime minister update
where we are in this situation
and um you know this went on for like
two or three weeks the problem
i had was some guys were starting to
come in and it was trying to hide them
you know to keep them out of view
because there was other private security
companies there
who i knew i had a great reputation in
in libya
and they're like oh what what are you
doing dean i'm not i'm reviewing my
evacuation plans it's like
you know the guys do look very special
forces
so this went on for about three weeks
and um
putting all the planning into place
doing all our recce using
his private jet you know to fly over the
areas identifying
you know if there's any aircraft we can
utilize you know we're at the top of the
the equipment list we had kit coming in
from like plat attack you know all over
the world
um so yeah it was a big invoice and um
this
evening i went up to the prime minister
and he said look he said i need to go to
um
to new york tomorrow it's the u.n
conference
but each evening he said please come up
brief up the health minister that's fine
so the following evening i went upstairs
and the health minister said
and so now the prime minister went to
new york he's in new york now you're
just alone with the
the health minister health industry who
actually turns out to be not the health
minister but a hospital manager from
london it's the only guy he could trust
so it's very closed doors
but in the in the corner over my left
was a a larger gentleman with a big
bushy
tash and he's just saying nothing so
mean health minister chatting away next
thing
he just starts screaming libyan they
start arguing in libya so i just pulled
my
pull my chair back and let it let it
quiet and down
i mean he just then started talking in
the perfect english
he said who are you and i told him who i
was and he said what are you doing here
and i
explained and he was the head of their
sis intelligence service and he said
no one knows this is happening in
government you know he's going the prime
minister's gone on his own back i was
like okay
and he said where are we with it i said
well this is a stage right you know
one or two more weeks and we're ready to
go and he's like he said i'm not saying
stop it but can we slow it down i'm
thinking yeah the daily wage we're on
i'm gonna slow it down as much as you
want
i said yeah of course so we uh i said
well look i'll tell you what we'll do
is why not we design a special forces
training program
for the libyans in the west and then and
the libyans and east because they
will never train together that way it
would be
cover the reason why there's equipment
coming in it would justify where this
guy is coming in so we went to an
agreement on that keep us all on payroll
drag this right out so um so that's
that's what we did anyway the you know
the government paying it was a third
party i can't mention who was paying for
this and about a week later they said
look
you know we are siphoning money yeah um
let's call it a day because we can pick
this up anytime
we can come back and pick up i said yeah
perfect let's do that so i sent
i started sending the guys back and one
of my best friends he stayed out with me
i said look we'll go back
tomorrow that evening we're in the um
there's a restaurant at the top of the
hotel a nice moroccan open-air
restaurant
and we could hear a distinct sound of an
ac-130
you know what a hercules aircraft sound
is like distinct and well that
that's a herc but there was four ac-130s
at military military airport around the
corner
but they were grounded they didn't work
because already done the recce on them
see if we could utilize them
thought nothing of it anyway the next
morning
all over the world news delta force had
come in and picked up an aq guy
responsible for the kenyan tanzania
bombings
so obviously the prime minister when
he'd gone into un had done an agreement
with the americans
giving it the green light which is fine
but of course
everyone thought that was me you know me
and my mate trying to get out the
airport that day
was difficult because and obviously
explaining to the other security
companies i said that that wasn't me
we got out um the prime minister got
back about three days later he got
arrested
by the militias he got released in the
end again people thought i was
responsible for that
i wasn't so i kept a low profile for
about a couple of weeks and i flew black
back in and i was winning contracts i
was getting some good contracts but i
wasn't getting
your oil and gas your ngos i wasn't
getting the big ones and i met a friend
who's an xsas guy
who's a security advisor for pmc um
oh sorry pwc and he says um he says
scotty everyone thinks you're
you're a mercenary we're not murdering
unless
it was sanctioned by the various
governments it was actually a show of
force
how quickly we could pull a private team
together
he said yeah we know that he said but
for the general you know
organic corporations who do their
diligence they don't see it like that
so then when it came to the canadian
embassy one
everyone had gone no security companies
were going to come back in and help the
canadians so when i came in
they said what what's the cost and i
said i think it was about seven thousand
dollars and that was to cover the fish
wagons my fixer
and i i charged nothing and i thought
what you know everyone's that you could
have made
but for me it was actually then brushed
off
that reputation of being immersed and
then put my name on the top of the pile
as being the number one did that
up for seven thousand dollars seven
thousand dollars we've got 24 uh sorry
22 people
a whole embassy safely as soon as
that's ridiculous yeah yeah my wife said
you should have charged yeah you could
have kept your reputation or
earned back your reputation and at least
made a little money on the side
but for me it's all about you know it
wasn't the money i liked like to help
people
and that's what i wanted to get across
and is that fact and
yeah it did yeah so then became number
one in the industry
yeah it's a lot it's a strategic move
obviously to to do that
and take care of those people and and
give them a good deal
and and clean your reputation up after
been a little bit you know tarnished by
this
involvement and and you know you go into
some details on the book on that about
just just the fact
that you know you can be sitting there
talking to the actual
prime minister of the country at the
time and
it's not what it looks like
no not um i'm exactly back up a little
bit this uh
one part in the book you're talking
about your new normal and this is what
you're doing
um your dad had been diagnosed with
cancer
you drove to the hospital when you got
to the hospital
your sisters are there your stepmom's
there they'd been there
kind of kind of just toiling with the
whole situation
you show up and put them on rotation
like hey i'm going home i'll be back in
the morning
um you know you need to get some sleep
because they were out there at the edge
and then you come back um
and you go into this the next eight
hours was probably the longest
continuous amount of time that we'd ever
spent together this is with your dad in
the hospital
he's in rough shape we had a bit of a
chat but it was superficial he was on
painkillers
but that had never been our style
anyways i knew i loved him
he knew i loved him and i knew he loved
me anything else i can do for you i
asked him he told me out of pain in his
leg
i saw he had a problem with one of his
pain relief devices i took a couple of
seconds to fix it
and instantly he looked serene and
nodded off to sleep
when the girls returned that evening he
was still peaceful
i've never seen him look so calm my
stepmom said
well that's because he hasn't got three
women fussing over him isn't it i joked
every squatty knows that dark humor is
how you cope with death
i stood up and gave my dad a pat on the
shoulder when we would be back
when will you be back one of my sisters
asked me i shook my head i won't
i'm going back to aberdeen they couldn't
believe it
i've said my goodbyes i told them and my
family are up in aberdeen that's where i
need to be
i knew it would be the last time that i
saw him and i was at peace with that
back in aberdeen that night i got news
that i had been expecting
how's your dad doing alana asked me the
next day at breakfast
he died last night i replied and went
back to eating my cereal
i was that blase about the whole thing i
didn't realize it then but death had
been
normalized for me so too at my ways of
coping with it
a complete numbing of my emotions my
father had passed away and i'd given my
wife the news
in the same way that i'd tell her that
the kettle had just boiled
over the next week or so i took control
of the practical side of my dad's death
i helped arrange the funeral and made
contact with the royal
engineers association so they could be
present
i wore my levats one of the ceremonial
uniforms of the royal marines and the
sbs
i wore my green beret my medals and my
father's it was the last time that i
wore the uniform
and i suppose that it was a true fitting
tribute in itself
my dad been a huge part of me beginning
in the my military journey
and now he was part of its end
how are you feeling alana asked me after
the funeral
i need to leave the house at 0-600 hours
tomorrow to get to the airport i told
her in reply
in a moment when most people are wracked
by emotion i was pr
planning my travel for the job in south
africa
i was relentless but in pursuit of what
and why
now obviously you know it's uh
something that you know we we
have to deal with death on on a big way
in in
especially when with with people that
you know i don't know how old your dad
was when he died but
yeah 67 i think yeah had her had a grown
son
and and and kids and had lived his life
and
you know i i know for me you know for us
it's hard because we see
we we see our friends that die that are
27 32 you know they they haven't had
that opportunity
and i think that's something that makes
a little sense in my head of
when someone older dies of course it's
sad but
you know that they had a good life and
they had that opportunity
and then like you said you know um
we unfortunately have to see a lot of
people dying you have to figure
out how to get through that
and sometimes maybe it's not the well
sometimes i guess we take the emotional
side of it and and have to stifle it
down
maybe not the best thing to do but it's
kind of what we do yeah
so it's how we deal with things like
with my
my father you know when i joined the
army that was it that was my new family
my one of my sisters
stayed with mum and my dad and my other
sister went up to her mom so they they
had their own lives so when i joined the
army that was
that was my family you know i would only
get in touch my dad was
old school you know i mean he i remember
getting a phone call he said you've got
to ring your dad a lot really
you know and it was because my cousin
had come over from australia he would
only ring if it was
really really important so i would do my
normal birthdays and christmas and that
was enough
no news was good news in my family my
dad sort of knew the score he would know
about me
coming back from a tour i wouldn't tell
him when i was going
so we we had that that relationship so
you know
we weren't close close um but i think it
was just after christmas
we knew he'd been diagnosed and and it
was terminal and things like that and my
sister
said you need to come down you need to
come down and i know
that she was being a bit overreactive
then her husband rang me and said
you now need to come down so i was like
yeah i'll come down and i went in there
and literally they're all
watching is every breath you know their
eyes were like piss holes in the snow
they had no sleep for like 24 hours
so i just flown in i hadn't seen him for
months i said right i'm just off to my
friend's house and uh what
i said because you know you you guys
tomorrow will
be useless you know i mean i just the
military just kicked in right we need to
do
centuries we when you do routines and i
remember my mum
calling me from manchester dean you need
to calm down it's like
you know they're they're upset you deal
with
death differently than they do but like
i said the eight hours i had with my dad
you know that was the longest i had and
you know for me i'd i'd said my goodbyes
and you know i i just i just went but
that was 2014 it was the same year that
i evacuated the canadian embassy
when i came back from that trip i did
the same thing again i sat down
and my normal sop would be to you know
de-service and resurface my kit
ready for the next phone call and one of
my shirts which was covered in blood
uh i'd administer first aid at a traffic
accident at the border
so i said to my wife i said can we get
the blood out and she could
yeah i want to know why there's blood in
there and i sort of said well i've just
evacuated
canadian enemies and she's like it's
another throwaway comment like you told
me
your dad's just died so actually we sat
down that evening
down two bottles of pork and yeah tears
started flowing and really and what it
was
is actually i hadn't come to terms with
the fact that i'd left
the special forces i was still trying to
match that adrenaline rush that i had
when i was still in
so everything even approaching the fact
that my father had died
that hadn't hadn't sunk in so as you
mentioned earlier
it takes a whole brigade to evacuate
something you know i didn't have that
top cover i didn't have the helo support
that the guy is coming in
so that's when the the pin dropped for
me that something needs
to change it was actually all about
communication and i i
built it up inside me it was that
evening that it really kicked in that
your dad's not here you you don't have
to prove a point
um anymore so um yeah it was a big i
think it's called
chapters called dead or divorced as well
so
you know i'd reach that t junction i was
either going to die or not have a family
right
if i didn't change the way my lifestyle
you um
one of the things that you breezed over
is when you when you did the world cup
in brazil
and um i'll just jump into
it it was at the brazil versus cameroon
game that i got a
chance to catch up with a friend of mine
he was there representing the football
association because his brother couldn't
make it
happy that my clients were secure with
the other lads i left
my place and went to the presidential
box to meet my mate from the army
all right snotty he said how are you
mate i asked him
we'd met back in 2007 at a joint
tactical air controller
sorry joint terminal attack controller
jtac horse
held at raf leeming there were 18
students and when we've been told to
behave towards a certain individual
as we would to anybody else in the
forces no special treatment
it was on the second day that we hit it
off when we were being given our call
signs
from the back of the room i'd made a
joke at his expense
and there was a sharp inhalation of
breath as everybody waited to see how it
would look
or see how he would see how he took it
he laughed and that was how
i came to be paired up for the rest of
the course with prince harry
who was one of the most decent blokes
you could meet he's a military man
through and through
and i think part of the reason he loved
the army so much was that he could just
be himself
he was comfortable in this environment
and he could handle his rank and job as
well as any
other soldier i'd met it was great to
see him in brazil
not because he was a prince but because
he was a comrade from my days in kit
just like one of the boys
how long was that course so that's a six
week course at least we're going back
now to
2007. and um you know
raf lehman you know he's got all your
fighter pilots
you know your tornadoes and your euro
fighters you know with their
with their brown shoes probably and the
um
and literally the raf the the jtac
course is a wooden hut
at the end of the runway you know no one
even knows we're there so i remember
walking in the room and
and clocking him he's probably about 23.
so basically this is when he
he wanted to go on his first tour to
afghanistan but he couldn't just go
on tour you know he had to have a role
within the unit and his commanding
officer was an sas guy and said well
look
go on your jtac course you could be the
regimental forward air controller
so that's what he did he came on the
course and like i said cody was there
you know every man and his dog turned up
for some face time with him
and you know it was cringing but the
back four
the the lads at the back four in the
back were two ses and two sbs guys
and he was literally sat in front of me
and you know everyone did their
opening address harry then left the room
and the commandant was like right
gets no preferential treatment you know
treat them like one in their own
you know blah blah blah that's that fine
harry then comes back in
and the first lecture is call signs so
on the course you call jackpot one to
jackpot one eight so at least the pilot
knows
who the student is and then you know for
example the prefix for
special boat service is mayhem some
mayhem for free and you know
widowmaker for the ses so harry puts his
hand up and he says um
you know if successful on this course do
i get a call sign and i just blurted out
yeah your fox pissed one
like that and of course everyone was
just like ah
you know you can't say that i'm just
like well you've just told me to treat
him like the one so he turns over you
know looks at the berry smiles at me
like oh god
i'm gonna get beheaded and um
that afternoon the sergeant major comes
back in and he's like right i've
randomly picked these jackpot numbers
you'll be working with me
and he pulled an sas guy an sbs guy
prince harry and an raf officer and then
the other 14 which didn't make sense
is that what you've randomly picked but
you could see
on the course that was when i got my
sort of first exposure so me and him got
partnered off because they knew
he wasn't going to get any preferential
treatment and i think you made that
quite clear that quite clear
but also the fact that he he's probably
is most comfortable there because he
wasn't being
critiqued by the media and everyone else
he could be
harry he could be you know lieutenant
whales and things like that and he was
actually
a good operator you know he's clear and
precise over the net he didn't get
flustered
um so no he's well worthy of that role
and and then we maintain that
relationship after that we you know we
we
did a lot together we do a lot in in
charity
and i remember going to we had a big
rugby game called the army navy
each year twickenham it's like it's the
biggest rugby event
hundred and fifty thousand people turn
up yeah yeah they drink more alcohol
on that one weekend than every
international rugby game so he was
my wife um alana she didn't really know
i knew him and i'd not long been injured
so my legs in a brace and we're out
twickenham and uh i
he texted me he said let's catch up in a
car park so we're caught up in a car
park and this was
this was now where he was training to be
a pilot and um
you know we started chatting and he said
look i've passed my course
i need to make a decision you know
whether i fly apache or lynx
and lynx is like a glorified taxi driver
for getting generals around
and when we're chatting to the uh the
apache call signs in afghan
their prefix is ugly you know ugly one
ugly too so i said look i always tell
the lads to go ugly early
um so he he that he then messaged me a
few days later and said yeah
i'm going ugly so he then goes apache
fast forward and
um we're at a big special forces charity
event and he's he's a guest on my table
and they auctioned off their special
boat service like um
statue silver plated they went for like
forty thousand pounds and harry's eye
was beautiful
not for 40 grand i knew i knew the
bronze one was only 75 pounds
so i did i i bought one and i i got it
um i got i got it laminated and i
and i said you know harry i said
congratulations on being ugly
you know mayhem for free and quite
delivered to the palace but um
but yeah he you know he did 10 years and
he then did another tour
you know that was where he was he was
most comfortable
and that's when we started you know
building our relationship you know
the re you know his gotta be so tight
who people he can trust and and to be
part of that 13 years later is a big
thing i think he knows
obviously the integrity of the special
forces you know you know people
i get message all the time can you speak
to harry yeah okay
yeah that's i just i wonder he's gonna
end up playing a role a little later
he is yeah um but going back to the dead
or divorced
section of this book um so you pretty
much
you get the message like i'm either
gonna get divorced or i'm gonna be dead
i don't like either one of those
outcomes so you you you
kind of stand down from the security
stuff and
you've got to get a job like a regular
job
so we'll go to the book here i needed a
job and alana suggested that i come work
with her in
the property development sector it would
be a chance for me to learn about
something outside kicking indoors and
sneaking people out of countries
and because i wanted what was best for
my family i gave it a go
i was about an hour into it before i
started to fantasize about launching
myself
out of the nearest window everything
that i'd done in my life i had done with
the ethos of unrelenting pursuit
pursuit of excellence the unrelenting
pursuit of
excellence and i tried to bring that
attitude into the office
but something was missing and you uh
you spent some time doing that and and
then she can tell that you're miserable
yeah and you're trying to suck it up
like a good
uh like a good man and finally she says
you know
you look miserable and you're like yeah
i am and she says why don't you when you
start biking to the office start cycling
to the office
and it's 10 miles each way you start
doing that
you're starting to that's cool hey
you're starting to get you're starting
to get after it you know on the bike and
trying to beat your times and all that
and she says you know basically you're
still not happy are you and
you admit to her like no i don't like
sitting in a cubicle or whatever it is
you're doing
and finally one day she she rolls in on
you and
you know she's holding something what's
that i asked her she had a book in her
hands
a big one alana threw it at me read it
and pick something she said
i looked down at what had landed in my
lap she knew me
i smiled open to the cover and began
reading guinness book
of world's record records
so that's what she did she threw this
book at you and said figure out what
figure out something to do
yeah yeah so so a bit about elana
actually you know when
when i transition you hear horror
stories when people transition from the
military some can be quite turbulent
and some quite smooth so when i met
alana actually she was the bank manager
for all the
three of the biggest banks in aberdeen
so when i'm worried about
you know certain paperwork she set up my
first security company
on her phone watching tv you know like
for me he's like wherever i've ticked
the right box so she
she knew about the corporate side which
helped my transition and and is a
massive part in in moving forward
so when i came back from the canadian
embassy the dead of divorcing it was
actually she thought i wanted to go away
and i thought that she needed me go away
to make money so it was actually a lack
of communication you know we sat down we
sort of communicated and she said well
look
we don't need money i've got my own
property business you know come
come work with me i said fine so
this is about five years now from
leaving the military to this stage of my
life my la my injured leg was now two
kilos lighter than my good leg
because of the muscle wasted so when i
was away on these security jobs
if there was a gym there i i took my trx
everywhere you know it was a very upper
body focus and
neglected my cv so i just bought a push
bike
sorry i gotta look at echo about that
he's skipping leg days bro he's going
out he's
just worried about those guns i don't
know anything about picking stuff
so i am so sorry about push bike of
amazon you know and bought some batman
lycra thinking it was cool
it wasn't um but i didn't know anything
about cycling
but straight away just it's only about
eight miles they aim about but being
physically active and you
felt that was a big weight off your
shoulders you know i can't run anymore
and i just thought perfect but you know
with my back stories sat in these
architects and planners meetings
i've got no interest in these drawings
and you know what i mean
my wife could see the glaze over my eyes
you know
i was more interested in the coffee and
the biscuits actually when my son was
born
i was the one holding the baby feeding
the baby while she was doing all the
work
and you just felt like you know is this
it is this all i've got
too often i i didn't want to be taking
those risks i did before
so i was about a month before my 40th
birthday and i was getting ground up
middle-aged christian ground rush and i
was like
i always remember doing i always
remember reading guinness book records
so you know i was thinking cycling
because it's not impacting my knee you
know maybe i should have had 12 ferrero
rochers in a minute or something
something a bit easier
but living in scotland i was thinking
maybe you know maybe aberdeen to
dundee's about 60 miles
my wife hadn't found the world's longest
road it was like from southern argentina
to northern alaska
so she was a that she clearly wanted me
out the house i was like [ __ ]
so it's like it's yeah it's 14 000 miles
it's called the pan american highway
called the pan american highway yeah so
you know to give you an idea because at
the curvature
of the earth it's just equivalent to
cycling from london to sydney
and then another four thousand miles
it's that big you know it's 22.
so i thought perfect you know so having
only cycle less than 20 miles i applied
for the world record which
you know some people think is quite
arrogant but i thought in my head i said
well no i have that endurance
mindset if the knee is not going to be
an issue then
then why not why why can't i do this so
i applied for the world record the world
record was 125 days
at this point and then six weeks later
guinness came back and said yes you've
been successful
on your application during this period
someone else has already beaten the
world record it's now 117 days
great so already i've got to take eight
days off my original plan
um so we mentioned harry already which
is perfect rolls into this so harry and
i you know we just do a lot in charity
stuff you know he used to come on on my
table
i had a an intelligence fusion cell
based in mozambique in tanzania so
you know these guys would give me in
reports of
where the ivory was going from africa
you know to the far east you know so i
would be
obviously pushing this information up
the line to harry would then be getting
out so we're doing a lot in charity
anyway so i
when guinness came back you know i rang
him up and i said look
i'm gonna cycle the world's longest road
and uh you know doing a world record
what should we do it and the
this was 2016. so his brother and
kate and him were about to launch a
campaign in 2017 called heads together
which was a
mental health campaign um in the
military i'd seen it firsthand you know
some of my friends you know
and but i wasn't aware how big an issue
is the whole of society you know it's
very much everyone talks about it
nowadays be from postnatal depression
young children teenagers all the way
through
so he said look could i do it for that
campaign i said yeah
harry asked would you do it you're not
gonna say no i said yeah of course
so um so he did that and then he then
introduced me to the royal foundation
who'd sort of deal with all their
charity work and um
the first you know you walk in the room
and they're like they're probably like i
want to harry's mates again
i sat down and they said right first
question is how much are you looking to
raise
and i thought i want to keep them at the
table i said a million pounds i just
showered out and uh but for me i wanted
the
enormity of the challenge to reflect how
much you know you can't go do like
the la marathon say you're going to
raise a million pounds has to be
in comparison i said fine i said what's
what is your messaging i was like [ __ ] i
didn't even thought about it harry just
told me to come in here i was like um
so i just thought about it and i said
well well physical activity
helps your mental state so i don't know
you can't use that
i said well why not i said well it's not
being scientifically proven
so i said it's fine i said but i don't
need a scientist to tell me that i feel
good when i'm
being physically active so i ignored
them anyway and carried on promoting
that and then obviously now
is very much recognized yeah it's one of
the coping mechanisms so
so that was the birth of the the
pan-american highway challenge
um sort of fell into it by accident and
the the
a lot of people doubted you because you
had
no experience on a bike you know these
other people that are setting these
records you know
they they that's what their life is
they're experienced
racers and whatever else and you just
decide yeah
watch this hold my beer
we the sponsored marketing team we did a
swot analysis that right at the
beginning it's just strengths and
weaknesses the opportunities and threats
and the only weakness it came about was
my arrogance towards the cycling
community which i took as a strength and
actually yeah cycling had evolved so
much from when i was a young boy
on a bmx and um but for me
it wasn't so much about the physical bit
i thought i'll deal with that on the
time it was the planning
you know one of the things we're good at
in the military is that meticulous
planning and the detail you know even in
the canadian embassy for if you have the
right plan
then you just bring that in you know so
i just took a military set of orders
and put it on here and i just crossed
out ammunition and that's when i started
started
putting the plan together but i was
taking experiences i had in the military
from before and sort of putting it into
this challenge i love the phrase that
you can't be experienced without
experiences
so i've had experiences before and then
what how can i sort of
transfer that onto this so one thing we
used to do in the special forces which i
thought was was great
uh it's not because like we're one of
the best in the world it's because we're
always evolving we're always learning
and always changing and
when we used to come off the ground we
used to do a thing called before we even
go clean your weapons and admin yourself
it's called a hot debrief you know while
it's still fresh in your mind and the
three questions that were posed were
what worked what didn't work
and if we were going to do that again
what would we do differently
so at the time i was reading magazines i
was buying books
about cycling you know but i wasn't
getting those
answers i needed and i thought well the
best people to speak to those
that have done it before you you know
they've been there they've been on that
road they'll they'll be able to give me
the answers
so i did i reached out to the previous
record holders and
i just posed those three questions and i
well getting all the information in and
all their issues they would all start
in alaska and finnish in argentina but
all their issues are in
south and central america so for me was
that
why take a gamble with the second half
you know why not get
you know bureaucracy at the borders
languages spares for your bikes why not
address those issues early
and then when you get into america we
can then reassess where we are
so one of the things i was proud of is
that i'd ignored everyone else and i
turned it on its head
my start point was from uh from southern
argentina so that's that's how i came up
with that plan
but there you know there's a lot more to
it than just grabbing a water bottle and
a helmet and cycling north
you know i mean when you're putting the
planning together you know i had a
support team and a documentary team who
are very much
more risk averse than myself you have to
be considered in their welfare
so there's things you you don't really
think about elections you know what's
the best time are you going to go
through a country in the middle of
elections there needs
civil unrest you know what's going to
give you the most advantage season wise
you know there's there's so much
which is what we do in the military you
know and that's that's what it was and
um
so that's where the planning came from
it's from what i i picked up before
and then training wise yeah i then you
know harry and i did a um
did a little promo video together to
promote the challenge and once cameras
finished he said
what training are you going to do and i
said well i'm going to do lansia and
john of groves land's engineer growth is
the southern point of england to
northern scotland
um because the pan american highway was
15 of them back to back
so i said if i can't do one how was i
going to do 15.
so i said i'm going to do that and he
said well i do it with some of the
members of the invictus games
i said yeah of course i can but i didn't
want to do it with them and embarrass
myself so i
haven't only cycled three weeks i rang
my mate and i said i'm going to go do
lands in john of gross and everyone's
that whoa you're not ready yet you don't
know you haven't even been cycling
you're not a bike fit and i thought bike
fit
was fitness it's actually your
measurements to your bike
yeah so i i just fooled me too oh yeah
yeah yeah so i sit off from cornwall
where the first two days was a huge
storm storm angus the third day i fell
off my bike fractured muscay void
i got up to scotland it was uh the
coldest it's been in
10 years it was -16 i
wrote off the first bike and my friend
just went and bought one off the shelf i
did everything
completely wrong in in in the cycling
world but for me
if i couldn't do one how was i gonna do
15.
and and then we then did it six months
later
with these guys and i was bike fit i
knew about
cadence and things like that and i
understand more the listeners in uk
is that landing genre growth is a is on
a bucket list for cyclists but for me it
was a training ride
and i almost had to approach it in that
manner
yeah well what i like about all this i
mean it's it's something i i've been
saying to veterans for a long time
which is you know when you get out you
got to find a new mission if you don't
have a new mission that's when things
start going sideways
and you know for you your first new
mission was doing the security stuff and
you did that you attacked that
and then all of a sudden you had to pull
back from that to take care of your
family
you you tried the new mission of the
cubicle and the the drawings
as you as you'd call them that that
wasn't a mission for you then you got
this in your head and now you had a new
mission something to focus on something
to do
a positive thing and uh you know
obviously takes
moves you in the right direction it's
just it's a it's a really great example
of something that i say all the time
that you actually executed
uh this is an interesting section here
um
it's called who dares win who dares wins
and you gotta you got a
unexpected call and the call the guy
says my name's andrew slater i'm a
television producer
and they had he had this idea they're
gonna take special forces soldiers and
gonna put civilians through
some kind of uh s form of
some kind of selection and as he's doing
this
uh you know you're he's interested in
having you be one of the guys
and the question was has this been
cleared through the mod through the
ministry of defense
and you start running this up the chain
of command
and you're you know asking if this can
happen or not
and then you get this going to the book
here a couple weeks later i received the
letter it wasn't exactly a pleasant memo
from the mod
it cut straight to the point telling me
to step away from the project
immediately
i read over the letter a couple of times
to make sure i had everything straight
but it was
literally in black and white step away
from the project
or become persona non-grata
yeah which is png means you're not
you're not welcome anymore
when it comes to decision making i
always listened to my gut instinct
and it was telling me loud and clear
that i should comply with the mod's
wishes
i was the sbs ambassador to scotland
and i enjoyed that role i enjoyed the
sbs association charity events
i enjoyed being able to visit poole and
hereford
i had good mates still in both did i
want to cut that away
in the vain hope of becoming the next
jason statham the answer was clear
i can't do the show i'm afraid mate i
told andrew
no worries he said we thought this could
be a problem have you approached the mod
about the show i asked him
you're going to have the same problem
with everyone unless the show gets
cleared
and you you go on you you end up saying
the show went ahead and as soon as it
became public knowledge there was a
shitstorm at the mod and in hereford and
poole
the production company and the guys had
pushed on without the mod signing off
and the sas and sbs immediately cleared
declared them
persona non grata they were not allowed
to attend any association events or to
be on camp
to give you any idea of how seriously
this was taken i'd heard of a former
general
who was persona non grata being escorted
off
camp in hereford from his own from his
own
friend's wake i didn't want to see that
happen to the guys but it was their
decision
and not for me to question personally i
felt that this sense of community was
important for my own happiness
and that wasn't worth giving worth
giving up i like the lads they're very
close
friends and so i felt for one of them
later
that year when i saw him at a black tie
event held
by the regiment he'd come as the guest
of someone who was still serving
but when the rsm saw him he was asked to
leave
he was he looked absolutely gutted and
who am i to blame him
it was in many ways like being cast out
of a family
so it's interesting too because the
reason that was interesting to me as
well because then you you wrote this
book yeah but obviously you clear this
book through the ministry of defense
um i've written i've written 49 books or
whatever the numbers at this point
and you know again it's always very
you know i remember the conversations
around when when i hadn't written a book
and just
saying like we're not going to do
anything that
yeah sheds any light that puts anything
we don't have anything bad to say about
the military about the seal teams like
that's
that's not what we're doing we're
obviously not giving away
any information that could be useful at
all
to the enemy um and you know that's
obviously of uh you know when when we
ran these books when i ran these books
through the chain of command you know we
it was like direct columns
with people that i knew and that were in
the military and senior ranking
positions and
they read them and said yeah these are
good to go and you know i had a great
senior officer who said
you know we're quiet professionals quiet
professionals but that doesn't mean
we're silent professionals
there's stories that need to be told
there's lessons that need to be passed
on so
you know look you you never feel good
about it because we're
we're we're not we're we don't want the
spotlight you're never gonna feel good
about it and there's always gonna be
guys that
are gonna look at you and say oh you
know there you are in the spotlight
and that they're they're totally i
understand them because i was that guy
too
and so i get it and there's that's just
the reality of the situation
um but it was interesting to see
how you had to go through that and and
make those decisions yourself
yeah i think i think for me at the time
when when andrew came up you know i said
your name keeps coming up
fine um and there was an old
documentary years called sasu tough
enough it was a massive failure and i
was like oh god that's all i had in my
head was visions of that
so it went on and ended up being one of
the most most successful film
um episode on on channel four and the
two guys i got on it you know one of
them
he just come out you know he got kicked
out of the military and then he went to
prison you know
for him you know there was no of other
option for him so him it was a lifeline
and then the other guy um foxy i'd say
it was foxy he
he had post-traumatic stress so but he
had post-traumatic stress because his
time
served in the special forces he couldn't
work in the private security sector for
so for them guys
it fitted perfect for them you know they
they had a means of income
for me at the time it didn't work
because i was smuggling people across
borders
and you know i was a relate you know
close relationship with harry you know
so at the time it then didn't look right
that
you were on tv say it wasn't you you
can't do it it's not because
as you touched on it people can learn
from the military
um and these sort of things are great
for that what upset the military with
this was that they
filmed it and then flanked them you know
so i've maybe now get my book out and
things like you know i've i'm still
part of the group and i do charity work
but i've been transparent
in everything i do and they understand i
think it was just the way that they'd
gone about it
in the fact that they caught them out by
by surprise
but for the for the two guys i got on
the show
you know they've now got successful
careers in that and
they probably if they didn't have this
show they'd probably really be
struggling you know coming out of prison
having posts from iss
but obviously the military also need to
understand that
it's a different world you know social
media you know
for me when i was in it was a taboo we
were talking about before you know it
is a way of communicating and obviously
as long as you
don't give away certain things then you
can there's nothing that you can't get
from the internet and that's it and a
lot of it is actually jealousy
you know a lot of it is actually
jealousy from those that are still in is
that
because they're not in that position
that they can they can do that but for
me at the time
i i just it just didn't didn't fit right
i'm gonna fast forward a little bit you
you know you
you're just training and you're
fundraising and you're getting ready and
you're doing all these
taking all these skills that you learn
from the military for planning and
endurance
and mindset and you and you get to a
point where
you're you're gonna launch this thing
and uh
you know you're you're supported on the
ground this is just so you you mentioned
it but you're supported on the ground by
a sports massage therapist a bike
mechanic a medic a two-man camera crew
that would be gathering footage to make
a documentary about the event it was a
big team
but with the exception of the
documentary crew everyone was doing it
pro bono
so it wasn't a huge strain on our
sponsors
um and then
finally we get to shortly after dawn on
1 february 2018
i went with my team to the starting
point of the pan-american highway i had
22 000 kilometers ahead of me and 110
days to do it
no crowds no big send off start freaking
peddling
yeah and you you you you cover a lot of
this um
in the book you know talking about what
what that's actually like what is what
you're going through
the wind the the crashes the traffic the
heat the cold
the illness the just the mayhem you know
you you talked about you go through four
seasons
while you do this you go through all
four seasons
and um so then you you you're making
progress
um and then one time i'm going to the
book here i got instantly worried when i
stopped for lunch and saw i'd missed
four calls from alana
usually she would just leave me a
message ask me to call her back
i worried that something had gone wrong
with the funding for the challenge or
worse still that something was
up with molly or tommy your kids i
facetimed her what's wrong i asked
what do you wear to a royal wedding
alana said i had no idea what she was
talking about
what do you mean what do you wear to a
royal wedding she said again
then lifted up a card so i could see it
alana and i had been
invited to harry and megan's wedding i
didn't see that one coming i told her
honestly
harry was a mate but a royal wedding
isn't for a few beers in the local
when is it alana smiled she knew that
i'd know the date was
the date i was due to finish in alaska
off by heart
19th of may she said and i heard myself
groan
that was four days earlier than i was
expected expecting to break the world
record
the last flight you can catch is on day
102
you better put your foot down
so you get the invite to go to the big
wedding yeah so
so the world record was 117 days and
when i was doing my planning
i thought you know there's certain
contingencies but those things that are
out of your control bit
natural disasters coups and things out
so i thought if i encounter any of them
on the challenge
you know i don't want to eat into the
challenge so my target was 110 days
um and it's because we had that that
fudge so you give yourself seven days of
fudge is that right i gave myself seven
days of
seven days of fudges should it be
something out of our control it wasn't
eaten into the record time it was eaten
into that and then i'd done all my
planning on that you know i
had a thing called the bible you know i
knew every inch of the road we'd planned
it out had it on paper had it on digital
we um no south america i did it in 48
days the world record was 58 days so i
took
10 days off the first world record and
as you touched on there you know you had
food poisoning
you had you had everything else but it
was things that i didn't see
as well you know when i was putting the
plan together not the medic i had to
send home you know it's not in the book
you know but i had to send the medic
home on day 13 because bullying
the documentary team it's like my god
the bike ride
was actually easier than managing eagles
egos you know because they're pro bono
they all started wanting
wanting more from the challenge as they
saw it evolving and thankfully my wife
was a campaign director she was sort of
managing
keeping control of that we got to i
talked about you know
going from south to north that was a
great decision from a psychic
perspective i've got
a tailwind all the way through peru
that's 2500 kilometers tailwind
but every checkpoint every border we're
having to swap vehicles so that was
slowing us down
so the plan was to have an rv and a 4x4
ship from fort lauderdale to to panama
so then when we
did the second part of the challenge
that would take us all the way to alaska
i was in ecuador and my wife who rang me
and she said that the vehicles haven't
gone on to the shipping container so
thankfully my wife
and my pa and two of my mates had four
sides they flew over to fort lauderdale
and they drove the vehicles four
thousand miles in eight days
my wife left the kids on mother's day
back in the uk
and they drove it all the way to panama
i broke the world record in the morning
flew across the daring gap and they just
handed the keys over
you know so they're an integral part of
this challenge you know
people see you on social media but it's
the team around you that they don't see
we then get to mexico and the mechanic
and a soft tissue therapist
these are our new terms and conditions
i'm now the project manager we're going
to change the name to this
here we go you know this has been going
on for like nearly two months now they
said you can't do this without us
i left them in pueblo see hold my my
beer
my mate then drove the rv and then we
just pushed on
we didn't have a mechanic but we weren't
far from the american border
so when i got to the american board i
got the american board on day 70 and i
was 14 days ahead of the world record i
didn't
realize how important it was getting to
america i don't know whether it was
because
everyone spoke our language i wasn't on
google translate for the last two and a
half months you know
the culinary options were better or
probably because the previous record
holders
all their issues were in south and
central have i left all that behind me
when now it should be a smooth road
and also the fact that if there is any
mechanical issues we can just get
another mechanic you know
we can find a massage partner that was
the hardest thing for my wife trying to
find a massage pilot which was the right
massage parlor
um so getting into america i was at 14
days ahead perfect
and then i had that phone call yeah
which was great
but i was now going into that phone
course 14 days ahead 10 minutes late i'm
now a day behind
so all that efforts i've done up until
then all that drama
has not that it meant nothing it's like
you've now got a new objective
so cycling in south america because
obviously
the support team and documentary and
being risk-averse you know i had to
consider them so i had to cycle from
first light to last light
and that was it and i was off the road
but getting into america it's a lot more
safer so i could cycle
at night and i got to lubbock in texas
the next day 60 mile an hour winds and
tornadoes so i was grounded for another
another uh 24 hours so i was now two
days behind my new target
so again i just looked at the plan
looked at the paperwork
and there's an app on your phone called
windy tv it's quite popular with sailors
and it gives you the strength and
directions of the winds forecasted every
hour
for the next two weeks it's about 95
percent accurate it's 95 percent
about 95 percent it's a great it's a
great app yeah and it was known as my
second wife on this because i was just
always looking at windy tv so for me to
get out of lubbock had to cycle 340
miles in 36 hours to miss the next
weather window
and that's what i did with north america
i just played chess with mother nature
through north america and majority of
cycling was done at night because you
know the wind
yeah less wind got to cheyenne picked up
the 50 mile an hour tailwind
and so it covered 260 miles in 11 hours
cycling so i was also using it
to my advantage so i i gained up that
time i had about 17 days originally on
november i did it in 11 and a half
and i thought perfect and then we got to
a town called white horse
about a week outside from the end and i
thought you know we'll record secure i'm
going to this wedding unless you get
eaten by grizzly
and then this gentleman's these guys
come on on
social media that day professional
cyclist he's already got three other
endurance world records mid-20s
sponsored by all the big brands red bull
and he's he's announced that he's going
to do the pan american highway in august
i'd be the first man to do 100 days so i
was like great
so every time i thought i had met my
objective you know it then moved
but thankfully for me if i'd known about
that at the start of the challenge if
i'd known about the wedding knowing
about this guy
you know i may not have pushed i may
have pushed myself too hard
um but thankfully when i received that
information i was in a position
that i could act on it so yeah i cycle
for you know the last two days
um i had 250 miles to do and it's
dalton's highways where they film ice
truckers
it's that road there and uh i thought
well i'll do 250 i do 150 miles today
and 100 miles on the last day and then
i'm in and my family of
my wife my kids are on on the on this
oil field in brudo bay
at the end so i know they're only a
couple of days away
did the first 50 miles and i got to this
roadblock
at noon and the gill's like no you can't
pass till 8 o'clock tonight
so i was like oh my god so that evening
i had to rest for eight hours and you're
not resting
um and i just cycled from eight o'clock
that night to seven o'clock the next
night 200 miles and minus 18
to make sure that i came in in 99 days
and 12 hours
so i talk about the importance of
planning but
actually the success of this was being
reactive to the situation
on the ground you have a plan that's
great you have a start point you have an
objective
but you know things change as you know
it's best planning will survive first
contact
um and that's what it was being you know
reactive to that situation and that even
to the very last day i was having to
change
change the plan yeah even the even when
you talked about the fudge factor
which some people would have planned
that and just had oh okay i got to be do
it in
225 days or 123 days cool that's what
they're going to book they don't
understand all the things that the
amount of room that they gives you to
make those adaptations when you need to
is
again that's something we learn about
that things are not going to go smooth
that's
one thing i can promise you um
i'm gonna read one more thing out of the
book here athletes talk a lot about
visualization
and how they had imagined their final
moment of victory again and again and
again
i'd done the same but now that i drew
close to the finish line
my moment was nothing like i had ever
imagined it
this was no ride along the
champs-elysees with me leaning back in
the seat with my hands in the air
i clung onto my handlebars for dear life
hitting one patch of black ice after
another my face was
covered in frozen snot my muscles were
shaking from fatigue and cold
and every blast of arctic wind cut
through me to the bone
but i made it
and there you go you skidded to the
finish line i pulled my wife and kids
into a hug i was so exhausted that i
probably can't remember what i said
i was probably talking gibberish but i'd
miss them all so much and they got big
kisses from their dad's cracked lips
molly was aware of what was going on and
full of beans but tommy was in a world
of his own
i thought it was i thought it must be
hallucinating when i saw the lady from
guinness
was braving the cold in tights in a
skirt but there wasn't one ounce of
discomfort on her face as she presented
me with my record
i was now the record holder for the
fastest cycle of the pan american
highway competing at 99 days
which also made me the first person to
ever do it in under a hundred
i hugged my wife but unlike in cartagena
this wasn't the place to stand around
for a post certificate photo shoot
let's get to the hotel i told my family
and team as we piled into vehicles
leaving the frostbitten finish line
behind us
so you made it and um
but that's not the end that's not the
end uh it's not the end of the book
and it's definitely definitely not the
end of the path that you're on right now
yeah because you needed a new mission
right
yeah tell us tell us what's up what's
your next challenge where are you where
are you heading next
yeah so so my usp is you know i take a
sport or discipline i've never done
before
and find the bill like his biggest
challenge so i've been arrogant
towards the cycling community it's now
going to be the kayaking community so
the next challenge is to
kayak the river nile the world's longest
river from source to sea so it's never
been done before
um so unlike there where i can speak to
previous record holders
it's not been done before so the plan
was obviously to do it last year and
obviously kobits
you know put scupper to that and that's
why i'm here in america you know
whilst the world is paused let's get
over here get set up
and get ready for that so yeah 4280
miles but
you know unlike truckers and and support
team you've got to worry i've got
crocodiles hippos
civil war in south sudan but one thing i
i'm excited about this challenge you
know i talk about
we've talked about the successful
private security missions it you know
everyone's quite quick to tarnish
certain communities
you know with one brush from what they
see with with tv
you know if it wasn't for those local
communities being so hospitable i would
never been
successful on them and that's where the
african nile is going to be great it's
because it's i'm gonna have to rely on
the locals
to help me and so you know it's not a
world record whatever i do
is the world record um but one of the
so that's the next challenge um but one
of the big feedbacks on the book is yes
great
endurance fee but you are the security
guru why are you still not
in this industry so for me i've got a
niche
security company you know very low key
we help
either corporates ultra high net worth
and things like because
paddling and cycling doesn't put food on
the table my wife keeps reminding me
uh so uh but yeah so i've set a date
first of february next year
and we set off for now it's gonna be
huge so you've got a team
you know obviously that's doing the
security work under your guidance so
what's the how do people get in
get in contact with you for that type of
business so we know
originally i wasn't going to have a
website and things like that but you
know
we will have a website that's password
protected because for me the
my approach to security is no there's
certain ways of security
ours is more intelligence based you know
you have the private
element you know we then have the
intelligence side of it and then and
then cyber
you know we don't you know i don't
normally walk around with
tight black t-shirts with tattoos out
you know we blend in
and things out and it's just having that
approach that i've used
before um so yeah if you go to my
website
you can get in touch with them but the
new website's getting built and that's
what i've been doing this last four
months is setting up the business
preparing for denial and next and your
website
is um dean stott i was calling you dean
scott i'm sure you've been called that a
million times
i was called i was calling you dean
stott or dean scott my wife was calling
you dean scott
so it's dean stott s s-t-o-t-t dot com
that's it is is where we can find you um
also you're on facebook
dean stot sbs you're on instagram
which echo only calls the gram at dean
stott
um it's real quick on the nile
what's the what's like the major
challenges
there what's the worst what's the what's
the hardest level rapids they have there
so merchant falls uh is the most
powerful waterfall in the world is grade
six
grade six waterfalls but the problem you
have with the waterfalls there is the
they take the the crocodiles and the
hippos from lake victoria and put them
in murchison
so when you come down there they're all
in the pools at the bottom
so originally when we were going to do
if it were a record they said oh you can
only use one boat
that's just not going to be feasible in
the 93 percent of knives quite flat so
we'll use like almost like a ski
um to go on that but then use a creek
boat for
grades three to four and then a raft
we'll have to use a raft on on some of
those big ones
are you gonna have like a sniper
overwatch for crocodiles
yeah there's gonna be a guy coming a guy
called peter meredith actually he's
he watched his friend get by a croc
kayaking in the drc
you know so he knows the nile inside out
you know he's talking about throwing
stones i'm thinking to use them
something a bit more powerful um but
local wise you know
i want to bring as many locals in as i
can because
especially the fishermen they know them
waterways better than anyone
so if there's crops and hippos in that
pool i'll just portage it you know
i'm gonna paddle through i'll walk walk
around it
message-wise you know we one thing we're
passionate about is modern slavery and
human trafficking and we're thinking of
using this challenge to promote that but
then that sort of
channels you into just just one campaign
the great thing about the nile is you
know it's the lifeline of africa we can
talk about poverty pollution
uh covet you know so we're to talk about
there's so many
so many things along the the the
challenge do you have a date
plan to launch that first of february i
set off
oh dang next year yeah one year yeah
yeah
wait a second you have to have a start
point i generally you have to have a
start but if you don't have a start
point
then the start just keeps the start
point becomes never yeah it comes never
keeps moving to the right you have a
start point and then you can start
approaching sponsors and start working
back
from that so it gives me a year now to
train at newport aquatic center
and uh you know then look out you know
get sponsorship
um the book is called relentless
uh that the subtitle is from sbs to
world record
breaker um echo you got anything else
how's your leg from that parachute
situation
yeah so when i actually started the the
training i went to see a doctor
and i was testing the strength for my
quads and my hamstring i mean it was it
was him that identified you you know
your leg is two kilos like
that really um when i set off in the
challenge
i got the muscle mass back my hamstring
was 18 percent less power but
you know it's still good no we're good
to go so
does it bother you like daily like
day-to-day kind of stuff
no no i i you know i joke that my wife
didn't marry me could i look like lance
armstrong or chris froome i try not
going leica as often as i can but um
you know for me any and i still try and
push it push on the bike now and then
yeah it was crazy yeah the um
i mean it's awesome it's awesome what
you've done to support these charities
as well
the the heads together and and i'm sure
you're gonna support some
some awesome charities for this next
event paddling the nile
hopefully you won't support the charity
of uh free food for hippos
and crocs but uh
yeah people can get this book on the uh
we'll put a link for it on the website
and yeah awesome you got any final any
final thoughts dean
no i think you know when you see the
website you'll see the frog man and
everyone's like
why the frogmen i always got the
question of what's the difference
between you
and the other guys and going back to my
original one my reason for going sbs
because i thought
you know they're all divers and they
weren't i ended up being the number one
frogman so
for me i'm not i'm not a cyclist i love
i love the water so we we have the nile
and then another one which jocko you're
more welcome and come along it's called
surfing with pirates gonna surf the
somali coastline
oh yeah that's that'll be fun that's not
surfing with pirates that's surfing with
sharks
exactly but again it's promoting these
these countries and you know
they're amazing countries as well but
obviously being as close to the water
as i can yeah i'm game i never got a
chance to go into small i sat off the
coast of somalia for months and months
in the in the 90s waiting to go in i
never got the chance
so i didn't get to operate i'll go get
some barrels let's let's rock and roll
well there's there's breaks and beaches
with no names actually so the plan is to
you know from the north to the south but
you know again people see what they see
on tv and make their assumptions
straight away when i was in mogadishu
again i work on my own and work with the
locals and i was like spear fishing for
lobsters and
and everything and you wouldn't think
you're in mogadishu because it hasn't
been
commercially fished for years there's a
huge abundance of wildlife there as well
yeah
i think my wife anyone you you'll pick
it up when you read the book
you know it's a team effort you know
my transition from the military
wouldn't have been this move it wasn't
for my wife we're very much we know our
strengths and weaknesses no my wife
can't ride a bike no i can
but my wife is very good at all the
planning i i and
she was key to the success of the
challenge
and the success of my time in the
security i generally believe that anyone
can break a world record if you take
away all those distractions you know
the business the mortgage you know who's
looking after the kids and and that's
what alana does
does really well and and and then again
my my young children have you know
nine and four i i sort of joke that when
my my son
when it was two and a half the the
challenge when we finished the challenge
you know the challenge was older than my
son so i think he just thought i was a
cyclist
and my daughter she was born after i
left the military so when i tell her
that you know dad was a soldier she said
dad you weren't a soldier so my son
thinks i'm a cyclist and my daughter
thinks i'm a walt with me
so i sort of joke about that but again
you know they're very
they very much look up to mum and dad
you know and they travel everywhere with
us
they've been all over the world they
know alaska south america in australia
and things like that so very lucky to
have that i think people
think once you have children that's it
that's your traveling days over you know
don't let them dictate
you know your life well awesome
uh thanks again for coming on and and
thank you for your service and and great
britain
has always been our strongest ally
and and we as nations have been through
hell and back together
in multiple wars and we know we can
count
on you in our darkest hour so thanks for
coming on sharing some of that with us
and uh good luck thank you please watch
out for those hippos
and with that dean stott has left the
building
talking about his incredibly incredible
journey pretty crazy stories
um the the relentless pursuit
of perfection yeah it's he writes about
that in the book
a lot i only read it once today but it's
in there quite a few times that mindset
the special
the british special forces mindset of
the relentless
pursuit of perfection awesome to have
him on here
and thanks to dean for coming on and
echo charles yes sir
speaking of a relentless pursuit of
perfection do you have any suggestions
that could
maybe enable our relentless
pursuit of perfection we're not going to
get there by the way
yeah but we're going to pursue it yeah i
will say
facilitate okay i said enable enable
and facilitate for sure okay look with
you are
are all of us trying to break guinness
world
records for the book we are not maybe
fast no factually not everyone's not
everyone's correct
but we're on a path though we're on our
own path right and that path is not easy
that's why we're on it
in fact if it's easy is it even a path
really not really
no i guess technically it's the path
of least resistance yes watch out for
that one that's a different kind of we
know that it leads downhill that path in
particular
we're not looking for that path we're
not looking for it we're not on it we're
not even
that's not our jam in any way but the
path that we are on is hard
obstacles pitfalls and traps wise men
once said but on that path you're gonna
endure
or you have to endure some sort of pain
in your joints depends on what you're
doing obviously but
most people are going to enjoy that yes
endure yeah
and look i'm not saying you should worry
about that and in fact if you really
don't want to worry about that guess
what jaco has some supplements
how about that for your joints okay
we've got josh i think there's anyone
that's curious about how you're going to
bring it all together
in one moment you know like oh here it
comes oh there he did he did it again
hey look we're over here trying to
sensationalize these things
to make them sensational okay hopefully
i don't think there's anything
sensational about it here's the deal
you don't want to have joint issues no
so you want to do things that
take care of your joints yes by joints i
mean shoulder
elbow elbow knee neck whatever yeah
you want to call it if it's a joint in
your body you don't want it to give you
issues no you don't want that nope so
that's why we made
joint warfare go to war against that
that decade and curl oil by the way
super krill oil yes yeah so now we don't
even have to worry about that kind of
stuff
so there's a lot of things you that you
should be concerned
about on this path distraction
temptation
if you will your friends sometimes and
let's face it your joints you know i
don't want to have to worry about that
kind of stuff take the joint warfare
every day with the super krill oil every
day
and you will not have to worry about
that kind of stuff yeah that's how it
works
get the subscription yeah so check it
out we are trying to
make things easier so you can stay on
the path more
so right now everything at jaco fuel if
you subscribe to it
then the shipping is free and look we
obviously
we are we understand that there's people
that don't want to
give their money to some giant companies
right this is part of it
also so they don't want to give money to
giant companies but big sometimes big
giant companies
ship stuff for free because they got
this mass you know economies of scales
and stuff
we understand that we understand that so
if you go to jockofield.com and you
subscribe to anything we're going to
ship it to you for free you don't have
to give your money
to some big giant company you don't have
to uh
do that it's fine we're here
jacofuel.com
subscribe get joint warfare get super
krill
get disciplined get vitamin d three for
your immune system get cold war free
any of these things mulk
multi flavors i just had i just
rotated mulk what'd you go into
milkshake where'd you go from
uh the peanut butter one okay but no i
don't i
rotate it no not the flavors i rotate it
into a daily or
more specifically a nightly got it i put
a banana in there
i think that's how for me from
indefinitely that's just how right now
get the kids on board
well my kids are all about these
different additives you know
yeah i'm good oh yeah malcold can you
get a um
subscription for the discipline cans yes
you can
yeah so yeah yep that's what we're doing
yeah so the discipline cans that's for
like
us who who kind of like are kind of down
for the energy drink scenario but are
not down
for the toxicity sugar
and all these bad elements that most of
the time come with energy drinks
that's what this is they do come with
energy drinks unless you get these
energy drinks exactly right that's
exactly my point so yes so discipline
go in a can there's also powder there's
also pills you can also get this stuff
you can get the cans at wawa and you can
get
all the stuff at the vitamin shop as
well and also
if you are doing jiu jitsu which is
recommended yes
look this is you want to talk about
something you're never going to be
you're never going to achieve perfection
in
jiu jitsu is definitely one of them but
it's going to help you in a lot of
different aspects if you're going to do
jiu jitsu
go to origin main.com get yourself a
geek get yourself a rash guard
and since you can't wear a ghee or a
rash guard while you can
john donner representing a rash guard in
the supermarket he doesn't care
all day all day all day
so what are you going to wear on your
legs right
you are going to wear g-pants to the
supermarket
low probability low probability how
about you wear a pair of jeans
cool origin jeans made in america
origin sweatshirts made in america this
is all origin
beanies whatever all made in america
boots
i hear some new stuff coming out with
the boot scenario
i'm no i'm in no position to talk about
it but i hear good things
from uh you know pete should follow
we're trying to make stuff happen that's
for sure
origin main.com all kinds of
american-made products where we are
bringing manufacturing
back to america get some it's true also
jocko has a store
so jacostore.com is where you can get
disciplined equals freedom
stuff shirts hoodies hats like that kind
of stuff
so we got disabled equals freedom we got
good we got standby to get some we gotta
get after it
anyway like i said drugstore.com that's
where
um if you see something cool on there
that you want to represent
while you're on this path that's where
you get it 100 we also have
something formerly known as the t-shirt
club
whack it's not really a club i guess
it's just it's a it's a
solid kinda is a club to be honest with
you but it's called the
shirt locker new shirt every month
boom by noo you don't mean like oh it's
just a new shirt it's a new design
redesign
it's kind of an okay i'm going to use
the word i'm going to use it exclusive
because you can't get it on the store
otherwise you assume i'm saying so you
sign up for this
people that are like really into the
game in the game on the path
representing hardware yes that's it so
yes jackosore.com
also subscribe to this podcast
and um you can do that wherever you get
a podcast we also have
jackal unraveling which which i can tell
you
daryl's in the house we're we're on it i
apologize it's been a while daryl's
wrapping up a bunch of stuff
in his world and so now we're gonna get
back in the game there grounded podcast
where am i even making claims on that
right now i
know we're we're not making claims okay
yeah warrior kid podcast i will make
claims on
i owe that one we'll get on it um
you can also join us at the underground
underground is where we're putting some
alternative podcasts maybe some
amplifying information some little
behind the scenes we're gonna do a q a
you were just telling me about some q
a where people can send video questions
yeah audio or
audio or video questions and you might
be like actually
featured like on it like your voice so
you know clear your throat
submit them boom yeah it'll be good i'll
make an announcement on where to send
them
yeah on what like a twitter instagram
scenario
something like that you'll know yeah
you'll know um
and and this is all from
jockowunderground.com and look it's cost
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
this is the platform
that we control so there's nobody that's
going to tell us what to do no sponsor's
going to tell us what to do no
platform's going to tell us what to do
we're going to do what we want to do
regardless and it's 8 18 cents a month
and if you can't afford that
that's okay we're not here to gouge no
if you can't afford it email assistance
jocko
underground.com and that's a little idea
that i heard from sam harris
sam harris same thing can't afford it
cool he we're not i'm not trying to hold
back information actually trying to keep
information free flowing because if
something ever happens to these
platforms
we're gonna need something somewhere to
go we'll have it a little contingency
plan is in action
so appreciate the support over there
that's true
also we do have a youtube channel it's
for the video version of this podcast
want to see what everybody looks like
and see what dean looks like
dean stott by the way if you want to see
what dean stott looks like if you want
to see any of these
you can check it out some excerpts on
there
yeah and also i i do a lot i do a lot of
work
as the assistant director with a lot of
these videos so if you see something you
like
just let me know that you enjoyed my
assistant directing
i feel like we all kind of enjoyed your
10
list of 10 things that you utilize on a
daily basis
i think i think that was kind of a cool
little hit that you guys kind of brought
i mentioned that my daughter kind of
drove
the the spirit behind that and people
think i think people think think that
that meant that she made it
mm-hmm she kind of did well she did but
editing oh she get did you get director
credit on that
yeah she does okay straight up good job
um yeah i do a lot of assistant
directing yes sir i understand
hey also origin usa has a little youtube
channel you can check that out if you
want to keep
updated as to what it's like to grow a
business yeah that's a good one
yeah they put all kinds of cool stuff on
their main tie
yeah hell yeah pete yeah be
little they're up there getting after it
you know what it's kind of like like
you know when you go to work like let's
say you go to work every day and you
kind of let's say i don't know you're a
manager i don't know whatever you go to
work every day and you kind of get
updated when you go in about okay what's
currently going on what's the status of
this what's it's kind of like that
when you when you watch like the youtube
things or or
sorry the the the origin youtube channel
origin hd yeah that's the one right
origin hd that's what i watch all the
time yeah the the interesting thing is
like
if you watch a reality television show
what they do is they take a bunch of
people with
like weird personalities yeah i'm not
saying in all cases but this is kind of
a stereotypical thing
take a bunch of people and then they can
fight with each other about whatever
right
yeah and so it creates drama for your tv
show
and then people watch it because they
like to watch a train wreck the thing
that's cool about
about what we're doing at origin when
you see behind the scenes it's not
it's not the team fighting with the team
right it's like hey how are we going to
make this work yeah you know
how are we going to get the right
materials how are we going to get this
in production how are we going to
satisfy this
this uh clients that we've got or the
customers how are we going to take care
of them
so it's that it's that struggle it's not
a struggle against there's no there's no
like uh reality television drama yeah
the producer like
and this is what they do by the way from
what i hear it's not like i watch this
kind of stuff but i hear
that they'll be like hey like there's
little writers there
that'll be like hey look we're gonna
send these people on a trip
um to the bahamas and hey you like you
gotta you gotta say that you don't wanna
go
because of what this lady said like last
month on instagram or something like
this and you better tell her
and we'll just see how it plays out kind
of a thing see and
just like your point though how whack
that is well you know
at the end of the day i agree but it
makes for good
cheap entertainment you know but yeah so
you watch the origin one
and it's like yeah it's not scripted
drama it's like the actual drama that
comes
with running and maintaining growing
like a business or whatever so yeah if
you're interested in like
how to run a business and what just the
whole that whole environment and the
process and all that oh man it's really
it gets real interesting
very interesting check so we got that
also we got an album called
psychological warfare
it's me talking to you through your
moments of weakness we got
flipsidecanvas.com which is dakota myers
company hang stuff on your wall
that'll keep you on the path got some
books obviously relentless
from sbs to world record breaker by dean
stott
we have that up we have it linked linked
books from the books final spin
a story is it a poem don't know is it a
novel
don't know i wrote it but i don't know
what to call it
if you want to try and categorize it
you're gonna have a hard time
the the the literary critics yeah yeah
they're gonna have a field day with that
one
we'll see we'll see how it shakes out
form leadership strategy and tactics
field manual
the code the evaluation the protocol
displays freedom field manual way of the
warrior kid four field manual way the
warrior kid one two and three mike and
the dragons about face my hackworth
i wrote the forward extreme ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership
i also have a leadership consultant
consultancy
it's called echelonfront
echelonfront.com we solve problems
through leadership ef online if you want
training for you for your company
on leadership if you want to get a line
go to efonline.com
we got the muster 2021 go to
extremeownership.com if you want to come
in
if you want to come and get after it
with us
you want to meet a bunch of people that
are all moving forward
on the leadership path everything we've
done is sold out these are going to sell
out too
so come early if you want ef overwatch
if you need leadership inside your team
in the civilian sector and you want
someone from the military that
understands the principles we talk about
all the time
go to efoverwatch.com and if you want to
help
service members active duty service
members retired service members their
families
gold star families check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization
and if you want to donate or you want to
get involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want
more of my if you just you're sitting
there thinking i could really use some
more of
jocko's interminable reading or we need
more of echo's
unrelated revelations related
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on
instagram or for echo the gram and on
facebook echo is adequate charles and i
am at jonker willing and dean stott is
at dean
stott sbs on facebook and dean stott
s-t-o-t-t
on the gram
and thanks to all military
members around the world and tonight
especially to the united kingdom
and i know that we rebelled against you
to form our own nation but we became
allies and we thank you for standing by
our side
on the battlefield the little island
with the heart of a lion and to our
police and law enforcement
firefighters and paramedics and emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and all first
responders
thank you for your continued service and
for being there for
us when we call and to everyone else
let me ask you this what are you doing
what are you doing are you doing
everything you can
are you who you want to be
are you who you are you who you are
capable of being
are you engaged in a relentless pursuit
of excellence and if you are
good then if you aren't well then you
just might want to pick a goal
and go get after it and until next time
this is echo and jocko out